this is Jocko podcast number 368 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
it was another day
we had been here
just over three months
and it was already
a historical deployment
the task unit was well known by everyone
in ramadi we had pushed the envelope and
taken huge risks to aggressively destroy
the enemy
who was ruthless and Evil
they killed innocent men women and
children beheaded local tribal leaders
and implanted roadside bombs that killed
and maimed American soldiers and Marines
we had already killed well over 100 of
these Demonic Enemy Fighters and in
doing so saved hundreds of American
soldiers and Marines
but it was a tough fight
brave warriors courageous soldiers and
marines died every day
from enemy sniper attacks IEDs and every
other weapon you can imagine including
mortars RPGs and heavy machine guns
valiantly these brave soldiers and
Marines fought on
day after day
week after week
month after bloody month
we had also suffered some casualties
the most serious of which was Cowie
who had been shot in the leg severely
wounding it during one of our first
operations
even as he lay in bed his leg torn apart
from hip to knee not knowing if he would
ever walk again
he pulled me in close and whispered to
me so the doctors wouldn't hear please
let me stay please
he wanted to be with his brothers
our other casualties were relatively
minor
we were blessed
especially when compared to some of the
other units that we were there with who
had lost dozens of men
one army battalion had arrived and lost
seven men during their first 36 hours
worth of Patrols
another Army company had lost a third of
its strength
in five months of fighting
we had been lucky
blessed and lucky
aggressiveness on the battlefield
certainly helped our luck
we fought hard and brought destruction
to the enemy
we forcefully pushed into areas where
the enemy was in control we went in with
a quick reaction force might not have
been able to help get us
the enemy was not ready for this
they had not been attacked so boldly and
mercilessly
We snuck in at night off of boats or in
the day with conventional forces we hid
in buildings next to their strongholds
we killed them as they slinked towards
our positions we surrounded their
neighborhoods without them knowing and
killed them as they prepared attacks on
American troops
the American commanders knew this
and love the seals because we were
helping to keep their brave men alive
our aggressive tactics and high number
of enemy kills earned us an incredible
reputation
the soldiers and Marines thought we were
unbelievable on the battlefield
efficient killers that had barely taken
any casualties
we were indestructible killing machines
there to save our fellow Americans and
destroy the enemies of our nation
that was their impression
but there was fear
self-preservation is a natural instinct
that is very powerful
fear is one of the most important tools
for self-preservation and it exists on
some level in every man
but this fear was overcome by courage
camaraderie
and faith
Mark was one of the greatest examples of
these qualities
he showed his courage consistently by
Leading from the front always in the
front of patrols ready to fight and
defend his brothers
his camaraderie was always evident as he
joked with everyone smiling and laughing
even as he was about to walk onto the
battlefield and even on the battlefield
itself
he was truly loved by all
finally the depth of his face faith was
immeasurable
he had an unbelievably strong
relationship with God and this was
reflected in his love for his family
who were always with him
in his heart
and on his mind
Mark's qualities helped soothe the fears
of everyone around him his Spirit was
contagious and it spread and comforted
all of us
he was a pillar of Courage
and so fear was defeated
and mission after mission would result
in the deaths of dozens of insurgents
and continued success for the seals as
we alongside our conventional Force
Brothers fought to win back the city
from The Wretched murderous insurgents
but the fighting was hard
I was in the Tactical operations center
the morning of August 2nd 2006.
Ryan had been wounded and was already
being flown to balad for further medical
attention
we did not know at this time how severe
his wounds would be but we were thankful
he was still alive
the city had erupted in violence
and the army unit we had fought
alongside for the last few months was in
the midst of a very tough battle they
believed they had identified where some
insurgents were located
Rafe called me and gave me an update on
the situation he told me their Iraqi
Army Partners were too scared to fight
then life said we're going back out
I knew that this was a bold statement
and that violent contact with the Enemy
was imminent
I replied simply Roger get some
this reply was not senseless bravado
it was a statement of fact encouragement
and Trust fact because there was a
vicious firefight and as proud fighting
men wrought with a strong sense of Duty
they all knew it was their duty to join
the fight no matter how dire the
situation
encouragement because we regularly use
this term to motivate ourselves and each
other during trying times and finally
trust because I did not have to question
what life and his platoon were doing
I didn't need to counsel him on their
plan or inquire about his tactical
decisions no they had proven themselves
to be a great combat unit
and I trusted them to perform with honor
and professionalism on the battlefield
I now focused my attention on the flat
screen televisions in the Tactical
operations center
a live video feed was coming in from
aircraft monitoring the battle
the picture was fading in and out and
was difficult to see but I followed as
tanks fired at buildings and cars and
soldiers maneuvered in the streets
I watched as two Bradley Fighting
Vehicles left combat Outpost falcon
foreign
I knew they were filled with seals
I watched as the Bradleys stopped that
one building engaged it and then stood
by while the seals assaulted
the seals were on small radio so I
couldn't hear them instead I listened on
the radio as the conventional company
Commander Captain Mike baima passed
information about the situation to his
Battalion Commander
my brother seals looked unbelievably
smooth fast and aggressive as they
stormed the suspected enemy building
I felt proud
after a few minutes they exited that
building and re-boarded the Bradleys
which then took them to another building
I listened as Mike baima managed the
battle space and directed forces
soon the seals entered another building
again looking smooth and aggressive
I couldn't believe how good my guys were
so professional so bold So Glorious
then
a minute later
I saw two seals carrying a motionless
man quickly out of the building
my heart sunk
we have a man down
I said to the Tactical operations center
maybe it's an Iraqi soldier someone
suggested
no they had no Iraqis with them it's one
of ours
the room got extremely quiet
I focused on the radio and listened for
details Mike bimo's working to get the
casualty to Charlie Med the medical
facility on Camp ramadi I still couldn't
hear late for any of the seals
then I heard Mike bye must say I need to
get this Kia moved
Kia killed in action
I gave the River City order Navy speak
for shutting down all external
Communications I told the person posting
operational updates to stop writing
the Tactical operations center watched
in silence
as the rest of the seals finished
securing the target building then left
loading back on the Bradleys
the Bradley's headed back toward combat
Outpost falcon
soon Leif got on one of the base station
radios and called Red Bull Six this is
Red Bull one six
I keyed up the radio Red Bull 1-6 this
is Red Bull Six go
life with so much emotion in his voice
that it almost sounded emotionless said
we had another casualty
I think he's k-i-a
this radio net was monitored by the
entire Brigade so we were both doing our
best to remain professional also to
prevent names of casualties from leaking
out we do not use names on the radio
instead everyone is assigned a platoon
number which consists of a letter for
their platoon and a number that
indicates who they are
we keep the platoon numbers in the
Tactical operations center on a board
I responded to Leif Roger
who is the casualty
there was a pause
and then he responded slowly and clearly
Charlie 1-4
I looked up at the board slowly
I didn't want to see the name
but there it was
Charlie 1-4
Mark Lee
I couldn't believe it
our pillar of courage and Faith it
seemed impossible
I asked Leif to confirm
can you confirm with his initials
Leif replied
Roger
Mike Lima
I replied
Mark was gone
it was pure devastation
we had lost one of our brothers and one
of our pillars of Courage
everyone in ramadi that wasn't actively
fighting
showed up
later that night to see Mark onto the
helicopter for his final flight home
it was late at night and the path from
the medical building to the Airfield was
lined with Sailors soldiers Marines and
Airmen
the forces we worked alongside were also
completely distraught by Mark's death
they thought we were indestructible
now they realized
we were Flesh and Blood like them
many of them knew mark
they remembered him
now they all knew
he was Flesh and Blood like them but
that made his courage and spirit all the
more profound
Charlie 1-4 Mark Lee
Mark will always be remembered not just
as a man a seal
a husband a brother a son
but as a hero
who personified love Faith
and courage
and one who inspires us all
we will never forget the gift that God
gave to us Mark Lee
who touched us so briefly but so deeply
he will be with us forever
and that is a
letter that I wrote
many years ago
to Mark Lee's mom
Debbie Lee who we call Mama Lee
and I wrote it to share with her what
Mark meant to us and one perspective
of what had
transpired
the day that he was killed
and Mama Lee was unbelievably strong
when Mark died and during our initial
calls to her
where we called with the intent of
offering her support and sympathy and
comfort
is actually the opposite that took place
it was she who
comforted us
it was mama Lee that was asking how is
everyone doing is there anything that
you guys need I am praying for all of
you
she was so strong
and she still is
but it certainly has not been easy
the loss of a child is unimaginable to
everyone
and yet somehow
she has endured
and she set an example for all of us to
follow
and it's an honor to have her with us
here tonight
to share with her
share with us some of her experiences
and her Lessons Learned and also to
share the story of the warrior and hero
that she raised Markley
Mama Lee thanks for joining us
you bet thanks for having me and I
remember when you sent that to me
and the impact
that it made when I read that and
obviously it's been 16 and a half years
since we lost mark
and still will you read that you know I
gotta you know lump in my throat and
making sure I keep it together here but
um I know how much you guys loved Mark
and I know how much that burden that you
guys carry
and as you've heard me often say you
know Mark was my kid who loved to give
gifts I mean he would spend hours it
wasn't a bag it and tag it get out of
here check mission accomplished he would
spend hours looking for just the perfect
gift and he would be so stinking excited
when he got that gift and I remember at
Christmas time he bought me a set of
gold flatware not solid gold but golden
color
and it matched my China perfectly I had
a gold room around my white China and he
was so excited and he came home and he
had it wrapped in the store
and he came home and he's like
mom wait did you see what I got for you
I'm like oh cool thanks honey and he
goes you gotta open it now Mom I'm like
no put it under the tree I don't have
anything to open Christmas Day if you
don't put it under there and he started
to rip the package open because he
couldn't wait he was so excited at what
he had found and he knew that it would
be something that would please me and he
ripped it open and showed it to me and I
realized after he passed away he tried
to explain the Brotherhood thing to me
before I'm like yeah yeah I get it
you're close to these guys but as close
as your brother you grew up with for 28
years
he's like yeah Mom that close
and I joked and I said well let me
remind you I didn't birth them so they
really can't be your brothers and we
left it at that and I had you know five
of his friends I mean you guys were all
still deployed but some of his swim
buddy and some others that first week
you know when he had been killed that
were in our house and I saw oh my gosh
they love Mark as much as we do and
they're hurting just as bad as we are
and I remember I think
you know the first time officially that
I had told the Charlie voice was I had
met with President Bush in October of
2006 and I was telling them all about
you guys I had the team picture there
you know and I remember even saying
Jocko willings there he goes well I've
heard that name before Jocko well you
know I'm like who is this Jocko willing
guy that you know even the Admiral when
we went in the day before the funeral
was you know talking about Jocko
Willington that you were crucial in
getting the Silver Star Award for him
and typically that takes a while and yet
we had it before the funeral was
presented posthumously to us but
um my final gift was you guys
you know and he intended for me to open
that immediately and get to know you
guys and that's why when you're deployed
it was you know we had phone calls it
wasn't just that first one you know we
emailed back and forth I got the team
picture and I put names on it so I could
learn the faces so when you guys came
home and
um that was Mark's final gift to me and
I knew it was a special gift in the
beginning
but man it is a Priceless gift that you
guys have been to me and to our mission
at America's Mighty Warriors and I love
you guys and so blessed to have you in
my life so
I know sometimes that gift is a little
bit more than you want from time
when um it was the timing of things the
way things happen uh General Brown who
is the socom Commander so he's the
four-star general in charge of all of
Special Operations
he
came to ramadi on August 2nd on a VIP
visit he was touring all of his all of
you know the troops the Special
Operations troops around the world and
he came to ramadi on August 2nd he got
there probably around lunchtime
and he stayed
and he actually was one of the people on
the flight line and you know I was I had
worked for Admiral Maguire
and Admiral McGuire
General General Brown had left and then
he had sent an email to Admiral McGuire
and Admiral McGuire forwarded the email
to me
and it was a beautiful email and he
basically described the situation of
what he had seen
of you know the the hundreds of soldiers
and marines that were outlining the
runway and or lining the pathway to the
runway and you know it's dark outside
there's chem lights along and it it's
it's in a war zone
and he he asked the question you know he
said all these guys are out here and and
this guy who I've you know we told him
about Mark we told him as much as we
could in a couple hours that he was
there
and general Brown
basically closed out the email with
where do we get such young men
and
I think that's you know a great way to
start off trying to figure out how you
raised Mark where he came from like
where did this guy who
was willing to give so much and it's
interesting you know we just had George
monsor on talking about Mikey and oddly
enough one of the things that he
mentioned was oh Mikey loved to give
gifts he would you know even if he had
to make them or find him out in the
street and put together something he
loved to give gifts and it's just
incredible that here's Mark same way
same mentality
but to dig down like let's start with
you a little bit where'd you grow up
um what would your parents do what was
going on with your life before before
Mark came yeah so I was born in Greeley
Colorado which is about an hour north of
Denver
kind of came in difficult circumstances
my mom at 17 had got pregnant with me
and there's two sides that I've heard
the story so I don't know which one's
true but um
for whatever reason my mom ended up not
marrying my biological father and you
know back then that was something that
was a terrible shame and so you tried
you know they sent the girls away for a
while or and my grandmother and I think
they were doing the best they could with
who they were and what was handed to
them but my grandmother wanting to
protect my mom and have me not born at a
wedlock
um
had my mom marry her boyfriend so my
mom's 17 this guy's 35. my mom told
different personality than me if that
had been me I'd be like thank you very
much I'll raise this child by myself I'm
not marrying that old fart you know
because at 17 that's a huge difference
and
um it was just supposed to be I guess
temporary and then have the marriage
annulled afterwards but that never
happened he was a police officer for the
City of Greeley and I didn't know any
different as a child wait did your
grandma give away her boyfriend to the
yeah
wow that's cool that's weird yes very
weird that's what I said it just but
again I think
with who they were with the lack of
Education they had
what they thought would be a solution
right you know you're not going to
really sleep whether you don't get any
of those privileges you're just gonna
get married then annul the marriage and
okay that's what they were saying I
think yeah I think that's what we were
born into that's what I suppose so then
did you grow up with your 17 year old
mom I did yes and what about brothers
and sisters um I'm the only child from
my biological dad I hate it when people
ask these questions sometimes because it
is a very dysfunctional family but um
again I didn't know he wasn't my father
until I was 16. so then they had twin
sisters a year after I was born one died
within 12 hours of birth and one died in
24 hours of birth so I didn't know them
you know I knew growing up that there
were twin sisters that had died and then
my mom and who I thought was my
biological dad had my brother Vance who
was two and a half years younger than me
and that's you know who I thought was my
family and who I grew up with my mom
went through a divorce when I was about
11 and then got pregnant again and
married
that the father of that baby and I was
kind of like a mom to him I was 13 and
my mom was you know trying to figure out
life and she was struggling herself you
know and so I was kind of his mama for a
while and then I left home when I was 16
so
that was when I found out who my dad was
and that's kind of when things all just
so when you find out who your dad was
did that just cause a reaction to be
like all right I'm out of here or did
you go live with him did you track him
down what happened did track him down
finally met him and of course when I was
11 I was five foot nine already my mom
was five foot six my dad was five foot
five there really weren't any tall
relatives and that's when you start
studying you know the biology and your
DNA and I'm like why am I some kind of
freak and I met my dad he was six foot
four as he tells me on the phone call
and five foot on the other he lost his
leg in a tractor accident the year that
I was born and so
um because the circumstances my mom and
I were fighting when you know she told
me about him she said you don't even
know who your dad is you know and again
you go back to that hurt people want to
hurt other people when they're hurting
of course being a little bit of a rebel
and strong will I said do you and of
course whack up across the side of the
face you know and that was disrespectful
and not called for but you know that's a
sensitive conversation that you sit down
and you prepare for a conversation to
tell somebody something like that not in
the moment of anger when you're fighting
so it caused a lot of problems you know
between my mom and I I did connect with
my dad and started to kind of get to
know him and found out I had another
brother
uh from the marriage he was in at the
time three siblings from his first
marriage and then he married again and
she had several kids so there's I'm
either an only child or I come from a
family of 13.
but again I think that's and I don't
want people at all to you know have a
pity party for me these as you go back
to Mark and how he was raised these
tough circumstances in my life
are what gave me the opportunity to
persevere and not quit and it's just
like when you guys are going through
you're training at buds they push you to
the limit to see what you can endure and
when you don't give up when you
persevere and when you have that
attitude man that's what prepared me for
the toughest day August 2nd you know
losing Mark where then I knew I could
still stand I knew it would be tough but
those tragedies and trials that you go
through in life I love school got good
grades in school as a cheerleader in
school so I had a blast I love school so
when you were 16 where'd you move out to
I went and lived with an aunt and then
but you're still going to school you're
getting good grades you're on a good
path are you thinking about going to
college what are you thinking about for
your future
um I didn't have real big goals at the
time I did get several scholarships that
I turned down because I just wanted to
be a wife and a mother the school that I
went to was
um
you know very poor part of town I was
one of the minorities you know it was
primarily Black and Hispanic in the
school
and all I everybody I was one of the
oldest at 18 I got married just weeks
after I turned 18. I was one of the
oldest to not you know latest to get
married or have kids that was what our
problem was what was the population of
your high school was it like a small
town well no it was in Denver it was a
suburb of Denver okay there was probably
300 in the total school but everyone's
just getting married well or getting
pregnant
having babies yeah and you get married
when you're 18 years old I get married
when I'm 18. and is this Mark's dad this
is all my kid's dad yes so Mary today
who was this dude
um he was you know played on the
football team
he was two years older than me
because I didn't have that Father Figure
growing up that really gave me love I I
didn't know what love was and I just
wanted to be loved and so you know some
of those things I interpreted you know
sexual relationship as love which it
wasn't you know but
that was the first time he used to walk
three miles to my house every night to
come see me which I like five miles a
day so I guess three miles isn't that
big but back then it was I was like holy
cow that's a you know and I was like
okay that's got to be What Love Is
and um
my mom forbid me to marry him like I
said I'm strong-willed and you don't
forbid a strong-willed person to do
something because that just pushes them
to prove to you
and literally
as a rebel that was the reason that I I
married you know intended for it to be
for life you know really thought that
that's what would happen had he
graduated from high school already he
had graduated from high school already
and what was he doing for a living
um
had been in trouble and
back then he he was a marine and was
because he'd been in trouble they're
like here's your option you go to jail
or you go in the Marines and so I didn't
know the extent of all of that you know
that that was the reason that he was in
the Marines but I think he had just
recently
that would have been 72 so probably just
recently got out of the Marines and so
we married had my first son Christopher
when I was 20 and had my daughter at 21.
and alcohol was something for him that
was he was an alcoholic but um Dr Jekyll
Mr Hyde when he drank and was very
abusive and finally tried to kill me
and at 23 I said and I think for me my
self-esteem was so bad back then
I felt like I deserved it and I don't
feel ever that that's the circumstance I
think the only time a guy should ever
hurt a woman if she's trying to kill him
you know and he's defending himself but
um
so it was it was some tough crazy times
you know and I was going to persevere
and show my mom I could make this work
but when it came to that point he used
to um
he'd act like in the beginning like he's
going to throw a punch at me and he'd
get right to my face and then he'd bring
his hand up to his nose and itch his
nose and he did that to Christopher at
three years old and I think that was for
me
the holy crap maybe I deserved it but my
kids don't
and so it was at that point you know
that I finally said and we separated we
were together and apart and together and
apart and together and apart but at that
point I was like I am done this is not
happening again
and because of all the violence in the
marriage the day that I filed for the
divorce it was final
two weeks later I was pregnant with Mark
and they heard two heartbeats the entire
time this was not when they did
ultrasounds you know to find out early
on you know where the health of the baby
or the sex of the baby and but they
always heard two heartbeats you knew
Mark I'm always like okay that's why I
thought he had two heartbeats but again
what a blessing and it's such a dark
time in my life and you talked about his
humor you know and the joy that he had
and even from a young age such a smiley
baby and giggly baby and he would tell
these knock-knock jokes he was probably
about four
and oh my gosh chocolate they were so
bad but he thought he was hilarious and
again knowing Mark you you can piece
this together he'd be laying on the
floor as a child he's laughing laughing
laughing and you couldn't help but laugh
at him
you know laughing at himself and so then
he thought he was really good but got
class clown two years in a row and I'm
like and that's gonna get you to college
how
but um what a blessing and what a gift
you know the struggles again you know
that you go through in life that we have
a choice
and we can let that defeat us
or we can overcome that and with the
perseverance that's you know what I
chose to do I wasn't going to quit I
wasn't going to give up you you put up
so much put up with so much in the
marriage but it sounds like the turning
point was when you saw that your husband
at the time
might hurt your kids and that was just
like the breaking point like I'm done
with this yeah now what do you do when
you're 23 years old you're got two kids
and you got one on the way where'd you
go how do you how do you get through
that
so um I was working at started working
for tectonics which is a manufacturer of
equip different electronic equipment and
it was a little bit a little bit better
paying job but still not a good job what
were you doing for them
um just assembling just a small
manufacturing line and that's not me at
all I mean I'm good at it I was skilled
I could you know I think a kid at 10
took 40 hours is what they you know
figured it should take you to build it
and I could build it in 36 and they're
like Checker QC she can't be doing this
right but there was no challenge once I
got that done you know I'm a very people
person so I need to do something where I
feel like I'm making a difference in
somebody's life and changing things had
several jobs you know one point I was
working three jobs 96 hours a week was
managing a bank during the day and I'm
not sure when we went through the
divorce of I was still working at one of
the banks but um
management Bank attending more at night
attending bar on the weekends you know
just just to take care of my kids I can
get any child support you know he didn't
take him at all he wasn't in their lives
who's watching the kids when all this is
going on I had him either in in-home
daycare or
um
in a child care center but basically the
second job was to pay for the child care
so
and then so this is all taking place is
this all taking place in Colorado still
yeah I'm still in Colorado at that point
and then the kids would start going to
school do you do you get on to like a
legit like a more regimented career path
at some point
um I would say was probably 28. when I
got a little more
goal already at that point it was just
survival you know I'm not thinking about
me or how you know looking ahead you
know I'm downward looking going okay I
gotta feed him I got to get clothes
we've got to be here we got to go there
and I was probably 28 then
when I had some health issues and it's
like okay
what do I really want to do what do I
want to be when I grow up
and that's when I I loved flying and I
was like you know what I'm going back to
school to be a pilot
and so at 28 with three little kids I
went back to school was at Metro State
College it's now a university in Denver
but
went back to school to become a pilot
and how'd that go well it went really
well until I fell and injured my back
and couldn't pass my first Class Medical
and again that was
I mean for my kids they've already been
through so much and now I'm going to fly
the friendly skies and someone else is
going to raise them when I'm gone and of
course I had fed myself the lies of it's
not
you know it's not the quantity of time
that I spend with them it's the quality
so if I'm only with them a couple days
I'll make that be good days out of the
month and I think part of it you know I
was so tired at that point of of trying
to maintain and do this all by myself
that it was kind of like okay that's my
little Escape yeah you're like maybe a
four day before they trip without an
airplane be all right get these little
rascals out of my hair for four days who
would have they been you know we
wouldn't have had Mark being a Navy SEAL
you know so did you make that connection
like you hurt your back and then you're
thinking you know what am I going to do
am I really going to fly around the
country while my kids are at yeah I
think it was after that point
um that was for me and I grew up in a
Christian home and you know accepted
Christ as a child but we didn't live it
in our home that wasn't taught to us
went to church on Sunday but that was
about it but for me that was when I
completely surrendered my life I had
made a mess of my life I had fought God
you know I thought he wanted to make me
into this mamsy pansy wimpy you know
have no backbone I'm like ain't going
there
and because I had made such a mess I
literally spent three months on my back
where I couldn't hardly roll over and
they didn't know if I'd walk again and
like the only place I could look was up
I'm like oh you were trying to get my
attention weren't you you used a two by
four and I ignored you and you used a
four by four and I just kept going and
now the freight train hit me and oh and
so I came to a place where I said I made
a mess in my life it's not much but what
I've got I'm laying at your feet you
take it and I'm not gonna pass go I'm
not gonna collect 200 I will stay here
and not get in trouble anymore just put
me on the Shelf I got it thank you for
your forgiveness of all I've done in my
life and uh
that was you know the point that he said
I made you the way you are why would I
want to make you a mamsy pansy wimpy you
know but I didn't understand who he was
so for me that was the major turning
point in my life where you know I
started reading my Bible every day
learning who he is studying you know his
character
and you know for me no doubt that was
the strength how I got through you know
losing Mark and continue to every single
day
but yeah so then what was it like so you
you make that turn in your life you you
kind of surrender yourself okay now I'm
gonna focus on what I've got and then
we'll then pragmatically what did that
look like in day to day like did you did
you get into what was your new job and
that now you can't fly anymore so what
what did you proceed with in that well
then I had um remarried just shortly
before that
um so you know he was the wage earner
for the family he was a long-haul
trucker and so at that point you know
we'd had some major problems
um with one of our kiddos and I was like
I just need to focus on them they've
been through so much you know they've
got to have some stability and how old
were they when you got remarried ah they
were 11 9 and 7 I believe
and how's that transition bringing the
new dad and on the scene it was rough
you know Christopher my oldest he'd been
the little man
you know and and he struggled and and
felt like because he wasn't the little
man anymore he wasn't loved and so oh
man we had some
crazy stuff you know that we had to work
through and so at that time you know I
really tried to focus on being a better
mom
helping them and supporting them
then we moved to Oregon my mom had a
preschool in kindergarten there and so
you know I started working with her I've
always loved kids and uh
she basically did Kindergarten first
grade and second grade so a private
Christian School at the beginning ages
and I started a preschool program for
her there and then eventually ended up
purchasing the school from her and
that's where you know my mission was was
these kids and loving on them and you
know
helping their parents raise them and be
the best they can you know when the
parents couldn't be there I still 100
believe if parents have the opportunity
to be home with your kids I know a lot
of them can't but make that sacrifice
for you know one of those parents to be
there because I think they turn out so
you know so different and people like oh
yeah I'll be there in the beginning
years I'll stay home no they need you
the teen years just as much as they do
in the beginning but I I understand
excuse me not everybody has the you know
ability to be able to do that so so when
you move to Oregon you got your new
husbands there and you're all kind of
like living a pretty normal life I mean
it sounds like you got three kids you
got your husband he's doing Long Haul
Trucking you got a decent job so it's
relatively stable
relatively
yeah I mean it was probably the most
stable that my kids had known and how
and how long did that stability last for
oh
I would say probably the
first four years maybe the marriage and
then started seeing some real issues you
know there was unfaithfulness on his
part and then he ended up taking his
life
28 years ago so
again a lot and like I said I never tell
all this all at once but you think back
there you're like oh my gosh how did any
of us you know turn out
but again that was the healing that
God's provided in my life and letting me
know that I am valuable that I am
precious that he loves me and not it's a
growing process I mean none of us become
a super Saint overnight and you know I'm
sure there are still things that I had
done or still do today that he's like
Deborah Sue what the heck are you doing
you know really but um I don't ever want
to do anything purposely that would
grieve him or upset him you know and
that's why for me I want to know what
are those things you don't like okay
well I'm not doing them then you know
and not that there aren't times like I
said that I'm sure I disappoint him I'm
not perfect by any means trust me ask my
kids they'll tell you
but um
that was the major turning point in my
life and I saw him get me through losing
my husband like I said it wasn't
a perfect marriage not that there is a
perfect marriage but we'd been married
for eight years you know there are
issues there
not that I wanted the guy dead but you
know
so now the kids are a little the kids
are older at this point they're 20 18
and 16.
so so Mark's 16 years old
and his
stepdad kills himself
hey what what's that like walking
through that with
I mean because you figure Chris is 20
you know your daughter's 18 like they're
a little bit more mature Mark's still 16
that's yeah there's a big difference
between 16 and 18 there's an even bigger
difference between 16 and 20. yeah
um
and how how is Mark handling of it I
think it was definitely Mark of the kids
that that was the roughest to go through
um I had almost been homeschooling my
children at that point I'm like I can't
I can't do this anymore going through
the grief you know run the preschool in
kindergarten and trying to homeschool
it's just too much so we put him in the
Christian School
and he came to me one day and said Mom
could you please homeschool me again
and my kids when they were homeschooled
they're always like oh my goodness and
we just go to school but I think now
they look back and see the blessings and
the life lessons that you learn in the
midst of that I don't think
homeschooling's for everybody you know
but yep I think that that was a blessing
um and so it was Mark's cry to say I
just want to I just want to be home with
you Mom I want to be where it's safe
you know and so I did you know started
homeschooling again you know and this is
before nowadays homeschooling is
relative a lot easier than it used to be
because I I homeschooled legendary my
wife my wife yeah incredible where
credit's due my wife did 80 of
homeschooling we just did it with one
kid
um and it's because you know
well you know in my opinion
from what I saw the school system was
built by Girl by women and it was very
well suited for girls meaning sit at the
desk and like do these things and like
my girls were a lot more okay with that
you got the freaking kid the boy their
antsy and jumping around and want to
break stuff and build stuff and it was a
lot to be cooped up in there yes and if
and my daughter's I've offered all my
kids well hey if you don't want to go to
school just tell me we'll figure
something out but they're all like no
which is weird it's you can't be mad at
me if you're thinking the old Yahoo
treated his daughter's different no I'm
telling you right now they all have the
option and if any of the girls would
have said hey I want to be homeschooled
be like awesome I wanted to homeschool
them I liked him being home more and you
wanted homeschool which in my family
meant you get to homeschool that means
you get to jiu jitsu all day you get to
Surf all day you get to leave a little
bit of math and whatever
but that's uh a cool way to go and I
offered it to my daughters
but they didn't they they didn't want to
do it I mean I tell that to my youngest
daughter right now I'm like hey if you
don't want to go to this you know
obviously oh you got homework she's like
yeah and I go cool you want to do it or
do you want to hang out with me because
we can just do the hang out with me
let's hope it's cool and Jesus says no
but uh but yeah but back in the day you
must have had to create your own
curriculum and everything I did and we
were we never had much money growing up
so that wasn't an option they didn't
have like you can today you know you can
sign up for online and if you have
teachers that instruct online but we
didn't have the money even the
curriculum that was available to go buy
that so I would go to the library I
tried to pick topics for them that you
know Mark back then loved Aviation like
awesome that's my background so I would
make you know the spelling the English
everything you know math you know let's
figure out how much you know gallons of
fuel you're gonna need for and make it
relatable and um
so you know that made it easier to teach
my daughter kind of self-taught herself
you know she would say okay by the end
of the year I have to be through this
book and I have to do that so I got to
break it down and
um but man you could it's such a shorter
day
we would and I did try to be structured
because it is too easy if you're not to
say we'll do that tomorrow let's go
surfing
um but we would school was from 9 to 12.
and we got everything done in that time
you know because you're not teaching 30
kids in the classroom the teachers you
direct attention
and then they could go have jobs they
could go you know be involved in sports
and athletic Mark played soccer you know
at the local high school because you
could do that you could take the extra
curricular activities and participate in
those and so Mark played soccer
at our high school and
what do you hear about like okay so
Mark's you know his first dad or his
biological dad's not around his his
stepdad comes in he kills himself like
you you can almost formulate in your
mind and there's not much money and
there's like stuff going on you
formulate in your mind this picture of
this guy
who must be you know kind of closed down
kind of angry kind of rough and like
you're caught it all it is just the
absolute complete opposite and and so
that was just always the case like from
birth because Mark lit up a room he was
always laughed like you couldn't you
couldn't
you couldn't suppress his happiness like
no you're not hard you tried it was
coming out and so that was it kind of
reminds me what you're talking about you
know when you're telling me that you at
some point in your life were sort of
felt like you needed to be meek and Mild
I it's hard for me to comprehend that
knowing you and then you look at kind of
the burden of life that was put upon
mark
and it's hard to like you just can't
suppress his just personality he's
unsuppressable yeah and so it was always
like that yes that was just just who
Mark was yeah
and I think you know you're that's
that's who God designed you to be
you know you can't be a classic if
you're that's not in in you you know you
could try but it's not going to be back
Champion
junior year senior year which is no
surprise at all so is it who's he
hanging out with who you know because
he's homeschooled so is he mostly is he
going to play sports at school he's
playing sports at school what's very
active in our youth group he was the
soccer player just soccer anything else
nope just soccer came home his freshman
year and he's like
hey Mom I'm gonna be a professional
soccer player and I'm like and I always
told my kids you put your mind to it you
can do anything you put your mind to and
when he came home and told me that I'm
like
um Mark you've never played soccer in
your life we didn't have the money for
them to play you know little league or
pee wee or he literally had never played
soccer and because we homeschooled them
it's not like you did it in you know PE
class
and I was like oh but this is what I've
taught him I'm like all right I'll get
you you know enrolled in the high school
at soccer and
okay let's do this
and that was after my husband had passed
so there was a little bit of money to at
least you know pay the fees and get him
in the program and it was uh his coach
was our youth pastor at our church and
good family friends
and after the funeral or maybe even at
the funeral chuck had said oh my gosh he
was probably the worst soccer player
he'd ever seen in his life
and Mark did his freshman year got most
improved player granted if you're the
worst soccer player in the world
you know that you don't have to go too
far to get most improved Flair he became
the youngest soccer coach that high
school had ever had and was in fact
trying out with the Colorado Rapids the
national team in out of Colorado and the
night before tryouts blew out his knee
had to come home and have surgery
towards meniscus
meniscus and his ACL had half his
meniscus removed which we had in the
refrigerator forever
um okay because you want to show
everybody but
um finally I'm like Mark throw that away
somebody's gonna come in think that's
something yeah but um and even missing
those parts of his body still became an
avco but it was really cool probably
three years ago the Colorado Rapids
reached out to me and they said we want
to present you Mark's team jersey we
know he'd have made the team and so got
to go up there and they had fireworks
for him they showed two different videos
three minutes long about Mark and just
honoring him and I was like Mark you got
your team jersey buddy
so yeah determination definitely one of
his characters so he's going to high
school but he's homeschooled you're
teaching him which means he's getting
straight A's I mean I hope right yeah no
he wasn't getting scared he was a little
hard time focusing at the time you know
Grandma got straight A's but he was
always 100
easy no I was probably harder on them
than I would have been those kids at the
school that were going through her so
but he's playing soccer so as he's you
know freshman year sophomore year
Juniors he's starting to think about
going to college
and is Christopher already in the Marine
Corps uh christers not in the Marine
Corps yeah but he's in uh living in
Colorado
and um then Mark had decided yeah he was
going to go to college he wanted to be a
youth pastor so he went down to the
Master's College uh just was that that's
in California just north of L.A Santa
Clarita and how's that for him it was
good he loved it it was doing great um
playing soccer for them there
and then after his first year when he
was home that summer and he did
construction work oh my gosh they would
say that guy will carry three sheets of
plywood all by himself up the stairs
but if you know Marcus he's built you
know big guy that's why he got the big
gun but um
yeah so to
see him you know do those things and and
carry on in the determination was
pretty amazing so he's going to college
I mean it sounds like this is as far as
I'm concerned like you raised a kid
they're now going to call they got into
college they're playing soccer this is
like a big win for you you I mean
Successful Mom right you're you're
thinking not successful mom but you know
I did my best but literally my kids
should have been their background should
somebody should have been you know
killed in a drug overdose somebody
Cheryl should have had you know 15 kids
by the time she was 20 and and I didn't
I just I was hoping if my kids got to 18
and nobody was pregnant nobody is an
alcoholic we're good yeah so you got a
kid that's what I'm saying you got a kid
that's right yes but again not because
of me and my skills as a parent you know
well I'm sorry to disagree with you but
you you had to do something right to get
these kids from a rough background and
here you got Mark he's going to college
he's playing soccer that's incredible
like playing soccer or playing any
athletic pursuit in college is awesome
and and so then how's that going so he's
going to be a youth pastor he's on a
good moral path everything's going
awesome Yep and then um when he came
home that summer decided he was going to
change his major from being a pastor he
now wanted to be a lawyer
and so in my warped sense of humor I say
first he was going to save him then he's
going to defend him and then he became a
seal and said I'll just kill him but
um obviously that's the terrorist none
but
um
and went one semester with the switch to
law back to the same school yep back to
the same school and then said you know
what I'm going to go pursue
you know Colorado Rapids and try to be a
professional soccer player so
I think that's what maybe he went in
between
maybe that's what it was in between the
first year then he went played soccer
and then decided when he blew out his
knee to go do one more semester
and that's when I really started seeing
him reading as he was recovering books
about other Navy Seals and what they'd
gone through again we they never had
swim lessons growing up you know we
didn't have a pool so I noticed he
started going to the local community
pool and
swim and Laps and reading about swimming
and you know so was there anyone that
told them about the SEAL Teams or did
you just find it somehow not that I know
of I don't know that we knew anybody or
he had any of those every kid he'd
watched you know a movie when he was 16
that said I want to be a Navy SEAL you
know every young boy at that age that
watches it thinks they're going to be a
cool Navy SEAL you know they get all the
girls they get to blow things up and
yeah best job ever yeah but I don't know
that there was anybody or nobody you
know obviously a homeschool nobody came
to school and talked to him about it but
my oldest son went in the Marines in
August of 2000. my daughter's husband
went in the Army in October of 2000. and
Mark went in in May of 2001 and I'm sure
being the youngest you know he's like
I'm gonna one-up you guys watch this
so very competitive
um but yeah so on 9 11 all three of my
kids lives were involved in the military
and I could see the handwriting in the
wall I knew we were going to have loved
ones deployed yeah you know and I
remember doing an interview at the the
town we lived in was about 5 000 people
and the reporter said you know I know
all your family's involved what if
someone dies and they say well God
forbid that would ever happen
but I've seen God walk me through death
before I know he would do it again
you know and who knew that August 2nd we
would end up
dealing with that but so proud of you
know all my kids choice to serve in the
military and to make a difference
because they loved God they loved our
country
they knew it was the right thing to do
to stand for and protect this nation
that we love and I I get so frustrated
at times that you know obviously for
those of us in the military we
understand that sacrifice and not just
the sacrifice that Mark gave of his life
what you guys have sacrificed in your
health what the families of sacrificed
for all the deployments that are gone
with the kids you know not having a
parent around
and it is so important for those
civilians to recognize that sacrifice
that is made so that we can live free
every day and when I autograph the books
that I'm contributing author and I sign
it live your life worthy of that
sacrifice and we do owe that to all of
our men and women who served to live
lives honoring them and recognizing you
know I don't think anybody unless
they've served or close to somebody
really completely understand that but
you need to try to understand it as much
as you can there's a huge price paid for
the freedoms that you enjoy every day
and don't ever take those for granted
as Mark's joining the Navy so
Christopher joins the Marine Corps
what's he doing in the Marine Corps
Christopher was and do you okay well no
it's fine because I was actually
Communications Communications but a lot
of people that aren't in the military
they don't even they're like oh you're
in the Marine Corps that's just like
what you're doing like every Marine is
just a marine and then you know oh so
you you oh you're going the Marine Corps
okay you know you got it and you could
kind of know what a marine is did you
have any clue about what a seal was
no I I really didn't I mean I knew there
were seals and they were special guys
but that was about the extent of it and
so when he enlisted when Mark enlisted
to be a seal did you start doing
research did you start trying to figure
out what was going on or were you just
like okay well sounds like it's gonna be
hard good luck go get some yeah pretty
much like I don't think my I was talking
about this yesterday with a guy I was
like I don't think my parents actually
understood anything that was going on
they they just you know I'm like oh I'm
going through some hard training they're
like okay
okay bye you know here I called him six
months later I made it through that hard
training I was talking about okay good
job you know okay great you know like
there was no there was no I don't think
they just comprehended whereas nowadays
there's so much information yes that you
can really sometimes I did watch the two
three four video okay well there you go
History Channel so that was actual
Geographic or okay yeah well no that's
that is a pretty there's a lot of
information it's definitely not
you know the way it's edited yeah it's
an introduction and it definitely is a
nice perspective it's a rose-colored
glasses you know on SEAL training a
little soft yeah uh
so Mark goes
and how you got what a son-in-law in the
Army you got a son in the Marine Corps
and so September 11th comes
and you're
yeah that is a heavy as a heavy deal for
you yeah I mean three for three yep
um when how how long is where's Mark at
When September 11th happens
so she must have been done with boot
camp was was he already at Bud's
I want to say he might have been down at
his a school might have been a day
school
so he's going to a school which is the
old way they used to do it you'd go to
like you'd learn a regular Navy job he
was a an aviation ordinance man ao2
Markley coming in hot that's before they
have their own you have your own job now
on the SEAL Teams it's called an Esso
Special Operation special operator or
something like that
um when he went to buds for the first
time well how's he doing was he ready
were you talking to him he was good his
mindset you know again looking back from
that side of it I felt like his mindset
was good he was determined he was gonna
you know he was gonna do this and
um he on Thursday night of hell week so
just the point he was an hour away from
being rolled forward they had done Med
checks on him and he had pneumonia and
he had pulmonary edema so he had water
in the lungs and water outside the lungs
and they pulled him from training and
even then he was like no no I got this I
can do this and they said no we lost a
guy two classes ago exactly we have to
pull you
and so as you can imagine very
devastated you know that that happened
he had to start all the way back at the
beginning you know wait for the next
class he was picking up trash or doing
something in between and you know very
frustrated but he's ready to go at it
again
and um
then that was class 239 that he started
in then 240 he started over again and
got to hell week and Monday night a hell
week he called me
and he said hey Mom I'm theor which
dropped on request request he rang the
bell and I'm like you know the joke
story is I'm like yeah whatever I know
how bad you wanted there's no way yeah
so what else is going on he goes Mom I'm
serious to ring the bell I'm like marks
knock it off you know this is not
something you joke about
he's like Mom it's Monday night a hell
week I wouldn't have privileges to call
you if I was still in hell week and I'm
like
I remember that from before
and of course when you ring the bell
then you steal the Navy time you don't
just go back home and get a new job and
move on with life note to anyone that's
listening that thinks you might want to
be a sealed just remember if you don't
make it which you probably won't
and I know you don't think it's you
you all don't think it's you you think
that oh I'm not going to be the one that
quits everybody thinks it's someone else
but most likely it's you
and I guess there's something I've heard
some people say like you actually know
like you actually know if you're gonna
make it or not I don't know if that's
true or not I know I was gonna make it
I'm not saying I was cocky I wasn't too
cargo I was still worried like you're
worried you're like damn I can fail or
something tomorrow and that could be
that and so that's why you're that's
even harder I was Paranoid the whole
time
uh but I was you know I had a pretty
good level of confidence like I know I'm
not gonna quit
so just keep that in mind so Mark and
this is also good to remember Mark quit
his first time through he did and
instead of being like okay well I'd give
up forever he's like okay so how how
long when you talked to him that night
was he what what do you have any idea
what drove that decision
um he had met a gal and fell in love and
he felt like this was not conducive to
Family Life which agreed okay it's tough
on Family Life once again anyone that's
listening yeah you think he might want
to do this job postpone the ladies
postpone the ladies they're not going to
help you get through this there's like
very rarely yeah so let's let's let's
hold off on the ladies until you get
done then you can go and find yourself
so Mark meets a girl
and he's a freaking romantic dude
anyways you know what I mean he's kind
of like a hopeless romantic and I'm sure
that he's kicking his ass too you know
pretty good looking yeah yeah uh I can't
judge that because I'm a man but I'm
sure if you ask a bunch of women they
would make that judgment yeah that he's
handsome
um
and kind of Jack too it's good yeah very
much so uh which is which is good to be
so when you're talking to him he's like
I met this girl did he have immediate
regret a lot of times people quit they
have immediate regret was he like no I
think I made the right call
what was his attitude yeah no he um was
sent to Virginia Beach was assigned to
the USS I always have to stop and think
of his Enterprise or Eisenhower
Eisenhower and it was in Dry Dock so he
was sent to the army base there to drive
a shuttle bus for them I have a picture
of him with his head on the steering
wheel like oh my God it's gone from
being Navy Seals now and picking up
people on the base on this bus and
um
Peyton life he was not happy and I
remember him calling me and saying mom I
screwed up I'm like what'd you do now he
goes I shouldn't rang the bell
and I said
are we positive we've prayed about this
he goes yeah Mom I need to go back I
said then you need to get your butt back
there you need to do whatever it takes
if you're sure this is where you're
supposed to be and where God wants you
you get do do it
and he had it took him about a year he
had to do meet with officers he had to
do extra PT he had to write essays I
mean the evals and stuff and rightfully
so how do they know you've already quit
once you know how do we know we get you
back there and spend all this money
training you and and you quit again
so he really had to prove himself and he
did and ended up being in running for
the honor man
and I remember he called that night he
goes mom I didn't get honor man and I'm
like Mark you got your Trident but I get
it I'm competitive you know but
um yeah did he train more or do you
think it was just the mindset was there
what happened to the girl
by the way she's still in his life at
that time so you know but he just
realized this is what I'm supposed to do
you know and like I told him if you do
not do him God designed you do you're
going to come home and kick the dog and
your wife you're gonna be fighting all
the time or your girlfriend or you know
you need to be where you're supposed to
be and so
um you know and again they're in
Virginia Beach I'm in Arizona at this
time so I didn't see a lot of that extra
training I'm sure he had to do extra
training you know Nora was real familiar
with what was going on with their
relationship at that time did he make it
through do you know if he made it
through like straight through in the
second the second time he went to buds I
think he made it straight through I
think there was one
pool comp maybe where they let him do
one more time yeah
so I think he he are you given a couple
tries in pool comp I think you yeah you
definitely get more than one but you get
a few tries and if you don't make it
then you get rolled back across you
never got rolled back okay he did the
pool comp the first time and then I
think he did it the second yeah I failed
pool comp the first time yep I failed
pool comp the first time I think yeah
and then I passed it my second time and
I was totally paranoid yeah but I'm
already preparing my my grandkids for
that just in case they want to do that
we do drown proofing in the pool at home
so that's good let's be safe I'm safe
I'm safe trust me uh yeah that's that's
impressive to get it through the first
time and and again I've I've had a
couple people that I've known
that had kids that went to buds that
quit and
if I think that they're good kids I will
tell them about Markley and Mikey
monster and I'll say yeah you know
Markley and Mike and Montour and they go
yeah and I go both those guys quit the
first time they went to buds
and if you learn from this you can go
back and you can you can get after it
and you can do awesome in the SEAL Teams
or if it's not for you then just accept
that and go do something else which is
perfectly fine yes it's not a job for
everyone there's different personalities
and there's different things it doesn't
make you a bad person if you don't make
it through SEAL training just means that
you weren't supposed to be a seal go be
something else and do something else
cool
which is fine but like you said if
that's what you really think you should
do
and I'll tell you another thing to watch
out for everybody if you're listening to
this and you're thinking this might be
the path for you it's
this is like when Mark's this is this is
during the war there's no war going on
right now
the second chances that were pretty
fairly common
are not that common right now and if you
quit right now people are like okay well
you don't really want to be here and
that's that so if you go
don't think that there's a second chance
don't go into an attitude with don't go
into it with the attitude there's a
second chance because likely at this
current time there's probably not going
to be a second chance for you uh just
because that's there's no war going on I
mean you're talking this is 2004 2005
like we needed seals and so those slots
were more open so did you come out to
graduation I did yep came out to the
graduation and one of my favorite
pictures that I have was Mark and I on
the O course after he graduated oh I've
seen that picture yeah love that picture
show he got yeah he got his Trident at
graduation right okay so this is the the
old way you didn't get your tried in a
graduation you went to a team so he got
his Trident at graduation and now he's
going to he gets assigned to Seal Team
three yep which to you that doesn't mean
anything you're just like well Seal Team
three sounds great no it does the best
team in the world so you're like okay
he's going to Seal Team three and how
fired up is Market this juncture he's
pretty fired yeah yeah he's I mean think
about it after going through
three Bloods classes you know you've
finally done it you're successful
you know there's a mission you know
you're going to be deploying soon
you know that's what he trained for yeah
he trained to make a difference in the
world and you know to get rid of the
evil that's out there
you know for our family for America for
everyone that lives here you know
because he knew it was the right thing
to do yeah sometimes people
think or their perception is that
someone will change buds will change
them some people have the attitude that
like no they didn't change the person
they just got rid of the people that
weren't that way in the first place what
did it look like to you with Mark yeah I
don't think it changed Mark you know
he's always been the determination when
he puts his mind you know we talk about
soccer coming home saying I'm going to
be a professional soccer player you know
then he followed through it didn't just
happen because he didn't do the hard
work to make it happen I can remember
him on Saturdays we got a ball machine
that would shoot the balls at him so he
could you know practice dribbling or
heading it or and he'd be out there for
eight hours on a Saturday what what 16
17 year old do you know that's going to
be that determined to reach his goal by
giving up his Saturdays to be able to do
that and so that's that's who Mark was I
don't think it changed him I think
there's some things that might have you
know habits that he developed maybe a
little bit different
but it didn't change who Mark was yeah
you know yeah and again
um like you can just see that he has
just an unsuppressable personality of
fun and and so yeah that's not going to
change
um so when when Mark showed up to Seal
Team three he actually got assigned to
task unit Charlie
that's what he got assigned to is that
the original one he got that's the
original one he got assigned to so he
got assigned a task unit Charlie so I
forget which platoon he was in but he's
either in Echo or Fox Okay so he's an
echo platoon at Seal Team three and
we're all going through I didn't know
Mark at all didn't you know he's in a
different task unit he's a new guy in a
different task unit I'm in tasking to
Bruiser but we're you know we're all
doing different training so we're not
even even though we're at the same team
we're not we're rarely all together you
know they're the desert we're at the
jungle we're at the ocean they're at the
mount like so you're so you don't really
get to know people right away in one
workup for sure uh and then what happens
is it's asking a Bruiser there's
different task units going to different
parts of the world and they had to send
one task unit to Iraq and another task
unit was going to go to the Pacific
Theater and
gets chosen to go to Iraq and when that
happens we get an opportunity to bring a
couple more guys in from the task unit
that was going to the Pacific
and so we got to sign a couple guys one
of those guys is Mark and um
Mark shows up and you know so he shows
up he's a new guy
he he had some buddies in there you know
from that were other new guys and
whatnot but like you just get a guy
that's showing up and it's probably the
best move as a new guy
to a platoon or into a task unit and our
task unit was definitely I mean we were
called to asking a Bruiser and we were
we we were definitely what's up to your
name yeah we were definitely an
aggressive group of dudes and probably
the best call would have been to kind of
gray man you know that expression gray
man get in there lay low let me just
like kind of fit into this gig and I'm
not gonna stand out and that's what I'm
gonna do not work no Mark was Mark was
freaking not like that at all he was out
of the gate like but the weird thing was
in the SEAL Teams
the primary as a new guy in the SEAL
Teams the primary role the primary
result of your mouth is to get you in
trouble like any time you open your
mouth there's a 90 chance you're gonna
get yourself into trouble you're gonna
end up you know saying something you
should have said doing you know
offending someone you shouldn't offend
it it's it's probably going to get you
in trouble
and so that's one of those things that
makes people go hey look I don't need to
roll the dice on this I'm just going to
keep my mouth shut
and Mark was just not like that but the
interesting thing was
his mouth didn't get him into trouble it
kind of it was like getting people yeah
and it made it was he's very endearing
and and had that like childish sort of
fun thing where you really couldn't be
mad at him like even if he said
something that normally would have made
someone Rage with anger the way he would
say it and the way he would laugh about
it and the way he would shrug his
shoulders and you know raise his
eyebrows like hey you know you know as a
matter of fact there's a video of Mark
and he's like doing something in a car
I've searched and searched for I haven't
been able to find it have you seen the
video where like marks in a car and he's
like singing a song and yes but I don't
know who's got it I don't know who's got
that but it's it's hilarious it's the
type of thing where you go yep that's it
how could you be mad at that guy like it
doesn't matter if what he's saying to
you when he's acting like that you can't
be mad at him okay try parenting
something like that oh he had to be yeah
he must have got away with he must have
got away with pretty much anything
because
um
so interestingly when he rolled in so
he's so he's automatically like I think
one of the first things he said was like
I can't be choked out you know like I
can't be choked out he's laughing and
he's getting choked out but it's like no
one's mad at him they're just laughing
like it's hilarious uh one of our so so
we're done with our pre-deployment
training so now we're in our sort of um
like we're doing sort of specialized
training that we want to focus on and we
end up doing this trip where we go to
Hawthorne Nevada
and we go to Nellis Air Force Base which
what this means is Nellis Air Force Base
is just outside of Las Vegas and
Hawthorne is like within
a short drive of Reno and Tahoe so we
end up getting awesome training while
we're also having like an awesome time
pre-deployment we're ready to rock and
roll
and this is where uh when we're and this
is where you know we really started to
see Mark and what he was like
um
we end up
and I don't know if I don't know if
there's a what is it a uh
what's the word for like when you can't
get in trouble for anything anymore like
a diplomatic immunity you're not
diplomatic it's when too much time has
passed oh statute of limitations so I
don't know if there's a statute of
limitations on stuff on my kids say
there is so okay so I'm gonna assume
we're past it but here we are this is
where where a seal task unit and we're
going to train in these two places we
end up in Vegas and while we're in Vegas
instead of staying like on the base
that's up there we stay we get like a
wing of a casino
we have we're there and we're training
hard but then at night we're coming back
and it's like we got casinos we got
booze and clubs and all this stuff
and this is where really like Mark is
just on fire well he's got an audience
oh he's got an audience he's like living
the dream and of course when you're a
young seal you're the richest person in
the world you've got more money than you
ever know what to do with and there's
some classic Mark Lee lines which a
number one playing Blackjack like we're
all sitting around the Blackjack play uh
table and playing and every time the
dealer would bust mark would just be
like everybody's a winner and he's got
everyone saying this and it's like
embarrassing the freaking dealer and the
cause and all like legitimately like Pit
Bosses are coming over they're like
checking him out like what's going on
here then like one time they're they're
uh they bring in other dealers like they
want to cool down the table like they
bring in a cooler and and mark would be
like oh they think they're bringing in
the Iceman
you can't do it he's like talking this
just immense amount of [__] to these to
these uh to these dealers and he's just
a freaking Maniac I remember
um I like come down to the casino floor
and I'm looking like across and I see
Mark and he's at a blackjack table and
he's like Hey sir I mean this is like a
public place Hey sir sir and I look over
and I'm like what's up and he goes hey
when are the new Cadillacs coming out I
mean he's just going nuts like
uncontrollable
um Mayhem right and this is this is what
you're dealing with with Mark it's just
like this Unstoppable unsuppressable
attitude doesn't just doesn't care what
anyone's thinking he's just having a
freaking blast and actually this is
there this is when I found out that Mark
was married
well you found out before we did I know
and and so what happened wasn't so I
didn't know he's married right and like
we're we're at we're sitting there
playing Blackjack and like it's we're
you know guys are starting to peel off
and like Hey we're going to the club
because most of the guys are single I'm
not single so I'm playing Blackjack and
so finally I'm like expecting Mark to
get up and go you know I'm like hey man
you know are you going to the club with
those guys what are you doing you're
gonna roll out you know you're gonna go
chase the girls or whatever like that's
what these guys are doing
and he's like he kind of like gets a
little quiet which was weird you know
he's like he's like hey
I'm actually I'm actually married and I
was like what he's like yeah he's like
yeah I'm Gonna Get You know we're gonna
do the real thing when I get back but
like I got an awesome girl and he was
totally stoked and that was that you
know so he was definitely he was
unofficially uh married at that time to
Maya and he was definitely in love with
her like
ridiculous and that's why he was just
content to hang out with the old guy
which was me at whatever I was 34 or
something like that like the oldest guy
in the world and he was contentious to
hang out with me and um
and waste our money gambling yep which
again and the Cadillac relates to
the the Charlie patch yeah I mean that's
the emblem on there is the Cadillac
emblem so yeah that was part of the
connection to the team too but I'm
thinking you know hey they should give
me a Cadillac right yeah they still use
that Seal Team three Charlie team still
uses that that Cadillac uh symbol which
has I think it came from actually the
platoon before is the guys that started
using it uh
so that was that was what it was like
that was the Mayhem up there and this
was this was Mark just
literally 24 hours a day yeah you know
because we're going out training and he
what's he doing he's just you know fired
up laughing poking fun of everybody you
know just doing like whatever random
athletic because he's a really awesome
athlete so whatever random like athletic
thing to try and do he's doing it
throwing rocks at the Target you know
jumping off this thing whatever he's
just sideways on any poles
he would do that the stop signs it's
just it's just 24 hours a day like oh
that's what he's doing
um
but you guys did try to you know the new
guys come to the platoon and you guys
try to make it terrible for them
and then I heard that they tried to do
that with Mark and after a couple days
you're like oh my gosh we love this guy
we can't we can't do this yeah that you
took bets on how long you'd carried the
gun with no sling the big gun yeah well
that that's what I was trying to get
across like most guys when they get into
a platoon they're just gonna be like
okay look I just need to be a gray man
and yeah you're right like the T the
guys in the platoon the more senior guys
it's just you're just fresh meat and
they're just sharks looking for a little
bit of weakness and then they're gonna
rip you apart and you know whatever's
gonna bother you they're going to figure
out what's gonna bother you
but whatever little name they can call
you or whatever thing they can do to you
flick your ear or hide your gear or call
you a name or poke you whatever it is
that they can do that they figure out is
going to make you mad they're gonna just
harp on that thing and and make your
life miserable so yes 100 that's what's
happening and they just can't find a
[__] in the armor of Mark like no
matter whatever he does that's stupid
he's laughing harder at himself than
anyone else laughing knock knock joke
so it's just it's just Mayhem and
uh and yeah and he's a really he's a
stud athlete so you know he's carrying
his his a dub his machine gun with no
sling and people oh yeah you're gonna
need that it's like oh no I'm actually a
I'm actually a badass
I got this oh you're a badass yeah watch
this and there you go and he's gonna
carry that pig with with with no sling
and that's that's how he's rolling yeah
and that's how he always rolled
um
so that's what we're doing we actually
then we do our our we finish that kind
of that those little blocks of training
that we're running ourselves we're we're
getting honed you know we're doing we
are doing a lot of legitimate hard
training we're putting all the junior
guys in charge so that they have better
understand of the leadership roles
they're we're doing a lot of standard
operating procedures we're really
drilling those so we are doing a lot of
work
uh while we're having this much fun we
finish up with those trains those little
blocks of training we do our operational
Readiness exercise which is like a big
training exercise where they have all
kinds of cool training assets and we're
out in the middle of the desert we're on
the army base uh Fort Irwin which is the
huge National Training Center for the
Army and they have
you know entire infantry brigades out
there that are doing their training so
that means we're doing interoperability
with tanks and soldiers and it's just
it's just really awesome we we had some
great training missions up there
and then we're going on deployment and
for deployment we're supposed to be
going to Baghdad and downtown Baghdad
there was uh there was a a group of
seals and Special Forces guys that have
been working with the most elite of the
Iraqi forces which is called the
Iraqi counter-terror group ICT Iraqi
counter-terror force ictf and these guys
had like American weapons and American
night vision so these guys were really
highly trained and that's what what we
were commission was supposed to be that
was our mission was supposed to be I
actually went on pre-deployment uh site
survey to go over there and
worked with them a little bit just to
get to know meet the people come back
with some you know Lessons Learned and
get ready for the deployment and we were
on pre-deployment leave
so guys are on pretty I'm not on pre-op
on the leaf but the everyone's on
pre-deployment leave and I get called in
by the CEO the commanding officer and he
says hey
we're going to consolidate all of our
Seal Team in the West in alambar
Province and that means instead of you
going to Baghdad we're thinking of
sending you to ramadi and
um at this point everybody knew how bad
ramadi was and I knew that that's where
everybody in Tuscany producer wanted to
go
I didn't let on that with the skipper I
played it like well geez sir that's a
really uh that's extreme change I might
need some extra gear and I might need
some extra people you're working it I
worked it I worked it with the the
skipper and he you know gave me some
good stuff and and that's what we did we
ended up we ended up going out there
um
and
I don't think I don't think Mark I don't
think we even told the guys because they
were on pre-deployment leave there's no
means of transmitting classified
information
to them and and so I don't think I don't
think we even told anybody until
everyone came back from pre-deployment
leave and we just brought everyone in
like hey we're we're not going to
Baghdad anymore we're going to ramadi so
I don't know did you know where he was
going I knew that he was going to Romani
but I don't remember now that you
mentioned that because he came home
before he deployed yeah and uh his
birthday is in March and it was you guys
deployed I think the end of March
beginning of April and so he was there
for his birthday and I had taken him to
we're just down the street from where
the Rangers rangers and the Royals do
their spring training and so I'd taken
him to a baseball game and had after the
well seventh or eighth Inning on the
marker board they put Happy 28th
birthday have a safe deployment love you
Mom
and you know in the game I'm like hey
Mark Mark look look Annie's just you
know nonchalantly drinking his beer and
acting like okay whatever no big deal
but the guy said when he got back and
they were he was all like guess what my
mom did for me but um
I remember when he was getting ready to
leave and uh pulling away Maya came with
him and as they were pulling away looked
at my older son and I said man I don't
feel good about this and I am not a
warrior or a fretter that is just not my
personality and Christopher is the same
way and he looked at me and said neither
do I mom and it's not like
every day that a black car pulled up on
my street that I'd be like oh my gosh
it's today the day I mean I prayed more
for Mark than anything I've ever prayed
for in my life but at some point I did
know he was going to ramadi and I've
been watching the news I knew ramadi was
you know as you guys say the hell hole
of Iraq are the worst piece of real
estate over there
but I really you know
knew that it was in God's hands whatever
the outcome was
but I think we all felt like you guys
were invincible
you're trained well you've got great
equipment
you know you're gonna be fine you're
gonna be good to go
you know I think we had lost you know
now looking back at it you know
Operation Red Wing was just the year
before
and I think in the community we felt
like we paid our dues
you know we'd paid the price we're good
to go and nothing's going to happen for
a while
and so I think when we lost Mark I think
was definitely a wake-up call in the
community go oh man well we are still
invisible there are still going to be
you know a cost here but I don't
remember if it was at that point I think
you're right I don't think he knew then
he just knew he was going to Iraq
and I think he may have called me before
he deployed and say I'm going to ramadi
once
once we were on the ground like how
often were you talking to Mark
um I would say I probably talked to him
at least once a week maybe did you what
did you think about what did you know
about what was going on there oh he was
training the Iraqis they weren't doing
anything real dangerous he was just
training the Iraqis and I do we had a
couple conversations and I'm like well
so what the heck's taking so long
training him for months I mean you're
just teaching them to shoot and how to
you know maneuver and do things
and he's like Mom they don't even know
the left hand from their right hand I'm
like wait what you know had a preschool
in kindergarten that's one of the first
things you teach these kids you know L
for left and you know your hand makes
the L
and I'm like I can't even comprehend you
know and so then the reality of the
language barrier and just some of their
customs and
um
but I think he you know pretty well
protected us to really know the extent
of you know he'd say I'm going out on a
mission but
you know and I know at one point he did
say that you know the numbers that you
guys
where you're at from your missions which
is way more than other you know SEAL
Teams had been doing
for the number of missions but I don't
think I completely understood I
obviously knew he was in a very
dangerous place I was watching all the
casualties come in every day
yeah I know it was weird for me because
when we got back like I had friends tell
me I wasn't thinking about this but like
guys in the SEAL Teams
they were reading the after actions
reports that would come out every day
and it'd be like oh this engage this
many gunfight here and they were just
super fired up they were like we knew
you guys were Frank again after they
were like they would read them at the
morning meeting like everyone would sit
down like read them aloud and I was like
damn like we didn't think about that we
were over we're just over there like Hey
we're submitting this and we didn't even
think about where these things were
going but then I know that on the news
and it was a weird thing on the news
because there wasn't there was very few
reporters out there in ramadi very few
reporters like when I was in Baghdad
there's a reporter like you you could
couldn't what does the expression swing
a dead cat without hitting a reporter
you could there was a lot of reporters
it's okay I'm not a cat lover there was
a lot of reporters but in ramadi there
was very few reporters and so who where
does the news come from it comes from
reporters so when there's not a lot of
reporters there's not a lot of
information now the casualty reports
were
would come in regularly and they would
say
two marines killed in alhambar Province
that's what they would say they wouldn't
usually say in the city of ramadi again
because there's no one there that's
really hyping the story of what was
going on in ramadi and so it was it was
I think it would have been hard to
really understand what was going on
um without without actually either if
they would had him you know reporters
that were there that were that were
actually putting out work because there
were some reporters there that were
reporting but they were on small uh like
small platforms and so it wasn't like
this it wasn't not wasn't on sale it
wasn't on Fox it wasn't like boom boom
boom they were like the uh Stars and
Stripes had some people that were out
there and so they would actually catch
some stories
but it was definitely a challenge to um
to figure out what was going on yeah and
that and outside of like I said my
friends in the SEAL Teams that would be
like bro we were reading your aars every
morning at quarters I was like that's
freaking awesome but outside of that I
mean my parents had my parents had no my
wife had a pretty limited idea
um and actually I've read the emails
that I wrote to my wife during this
deployment and they're like hey you know
I'm like hey how's everything uh you
know how are the kids like there's
literally almost nothing about the
actual deployment itself which is kind
of a bummer because I would want it now
to see what was going on but they're all
just very Bland
um but that's what as you know now I
mean that was that's what we were doing
that's what Mark was doing and Mark was
doing just uh an outstanding job
um across the board and one thing I know
you've heard a little bit about this but
you know
we were working with Iraqis
and some of my guys had a really hard
time forming relationships with Iraqis
and Mark did an awesome job of that I
know you know he they played soccer
there's a soccer stadium in downtown
ramadi a big giant soccer stadium and
not that we used it we used it for a
different purpose but
um Iraqis love to play soccer and so
here was Mark
you know of an actual skilled soccer
player and most well we didn't ever have
I don't think there had been skilled
soccer players there before from America
and so all of a sudden we had like a
championship team based about based
around one guy
based just around base just around Mark
being a badass and being a badass soccer
player and being able to beat them in
the game that they would usually you
know pulverize you guys pulverize the
Americans you know we they didn't ever
want to play American football Echo
Charles they didn't ever want to uh play
baseball they wanted to play soccer well
and I did hear that there is a football
field somewhere in ramadi that was named
after Mark that he had made such an
impression on those that they played
with of course you know because you guys
had won several of them they're like we
want a rematch and I said well that
rematch is going to have to happen in
heaven but yeah even then you know the
um my first trip over to Iraq I got to
meet The Interpreter that was with you
guys who had been sick that day and
didn't go out on that mission of course
he felt like that was his fault that we
lost Mark that if he could have been
there
you know he could have saved Mark and
like I've told so many others there was
somebody bigger in control that day you
know that not that God caused Mark's
death at all
but he could have stopped it and he
chose not to and I think we're blessed
16 and a half years later to see the
impact Mark's still making today and the
lives he is still saving his teammates
lives you know we were in an event
yesterday that was a a funeral for one
of our guys and um just as I kept
meeting people thinking oh my gosh this
is someone else that you know we've
helped through the foundation that
wouldn't have happened if it would have
been for the sacrifice that Mark chose
to make you know and you know soccer
field and ramadi you know trade-up
building you know that was named after
mark on the base
you know movies books you know and I
know we've been up to Mark's grave
before and I said man that's the hardest
thing to see your kid's name on
headstone you know that's not normal
that's not the way
life should be we should be living you
know full lives and dying in our old age
we have Heroes who did what Mark did and
what you guys did their stories need to
be told people need to understand the
sacrifices that are made and who these
guys are what their character is and how
you guys are some of the toughest
Warriors that we have in America and
I'll tell you what some of the most kind
compassionate caring man I've ever known
and how God gets that mixture together
in your body is it's absolutely amazing
so yeah
yeah and I think that's what made Mark
so amazing is he had the extreme of both
those facets
um you know like we're talking about and
we've talked about how how
insurpressible his personality was from
a just fun and humor
side
um
but like on the on the war fighting side
we mentioned you know he's out there
he's he's a machine gunner he's carrying
his machine gun with no sling
he's a lead turret Gunner in
the vehicles
which
night after night you know in Vietnam in
the Vietnam War
um the point man is the most vulnerable
guy because you're walking through a
jungle and you're having to break Trail
and as you break Trail guess what you
might hit a tripwire you might walk into
an ambush and you're going to get killed
and so what they did in Vietnam was they
rotate that guy out they go okay you do
it for you know an hour then we're gonna
get another guy up there for an hour
because you can't handle that much
vulnerability as a human
well in ramadi
the lead turret gunner in a vehicle
he's the most exposed guy because he's
up out of the vehicle on his machine on
his 50 caliber machine gun
and the primary threat in ramadi is
roadside bombs and so when you hit a
roadside bomb with a convoy
it's a person in the lead vehicle that's
in the turret that's gonna most likely
be killed or be great Gravely wounded
and the the horrible decision that
someone made in ramadi was to put the
vehicle what we called the vehicle
graveyard which is
75 or 100 vehicles that have been blown
up
in ramadi and when they drag them back
to base they would just put them on into
this field and you every time you left
base you would see a hundred of these
mangled Vehicles burned out vehicles and
every one of those Vehicles you know
that there was one two three four
military U.S military personnel that
were wounded or burned or killed inside
those vehicles and that's what you got
to see and so Mark going out
night after night lead vehicle lead
turret Gunner
never never said hey you know can I go
in the second vehicle can I go in the
Third vehicle can I go in the back never
one time just leave vehicle every time
just taking just taking the all the odds
and just saying I got it boys
don't worry about me and you know I I
would you know if I wasn't going on an
OP
you know has the vehicles were lined up
I'd go out like you know make sure
everyone's good to go I'd give him a
little hand salute as they were rolling
out and I was like it was Mar it had
been marked 38th mission in a row of
being in the lead vehicle
and I'm looking up at him and he's
looking down at me and I'm like hey bro
you you feeling good how you feeling
he's like I'm feeling lucky sir let's go
like that was his attitude big smile is
a big smile a a big giant smile on his
face
as he's getting ready for the 39th 40
47th time in a row to go out and go down
those roads where
the main road
route Michigan in ramadi had seven to
ten roadside bombs detonated on it a day
yeah
a day and that's what he's rolling out
to yeah and he's laughing yeah and he's
smiling
part of that
was he was Secure
he knew if anything happened not that he
wanted something to happen but he knew
if anything happened he knew he was
going
he knew when he got to Heaven there's no
pain no sorrow no sickness
you know lots of times I thought about
him up there in his honoriness I'm sure
God's maybe sometimes going oh boy maybe
we should send it back but but he's made
he's making you know have an exciting
that's for sure not that it might have
been exciting before but
yeah he had that confidence he knew that
it wasn't over for him it might be over
for him here on Earth
but he knew beyond a shadow of a doubt
where he's going
and you know oftentimes you know people
tell me oh yeah Mark's in Valhalla you
know Warriors Heaven you know because of
what he did for his country I'm like
okay well I would probably die from my
country if it was needed but I'm not
going to be at a place probably where
that's going to be required of me
but
he knew he knew a hundred percent you
know and for me then what's that mean
for me how do I get to heaven if I Gotta
Die for my country no Mark's in heaven
because he knew Jesus Christ was his
Lord and savior in the story you know
it's not based on what we do or what we
don't do or what we say or what we don't
say you know
Christ's already paid that price for us
and Mark knew that beyond a shadow of a
doubt and so I think that was the smile
on his face he wasn't scared you know he
may have had fear and had that courage
to push through it but he knew the end
of the story
yeah
after seeing a lot of guys and a lot of
tough situations
to not be able to really pick up an
ounce of like hesitation from a guy is
very rare yeah it's very rare and so he
definitely knew because you're gonna
you're gonna show something yeah and he
didn't didn't have any fear yeah yeah
which is
incredible
um
so this is now like we're getting we've
been on deployment did you did you know
Cowie came home did you were even aware
of that no no so you're I really did not
know a lot about the team I had met
Bobby gasoff who was his swim buddy uh
and I think Maddie long
um who was on three but not on Charlie
platoon or Tuscany Bruiser I met them
briefly at graduation but I didn't know
any of the other guys didn't know
anything about really what was going on
well you know obviously what I know now
is what I've learned afterwards but yeah
yeah so you're
kind of tracking and again to me
it always and I kind of related to my
family because my family is
my wife just not knowing what's going on
like she's just and she I don't I think
in a lot of ways she doesn't even want
to know she's like hey you go do your
thing I do my thing you take care of it
and same thing with my like my my kids
they were young at the time so they were
just you know I was just dad he's not
here where is he yeah I don't know but
he's not here he'll be home in a little
while my parents just I had been in the
Navy my whole you know adult life they
were just used to me going on a plane
that they wouldn't hear from me for a
month or two and then I'd you know
everything's cool so I think that sounds
like that's where you were at too like
hey son's unemployment there that's
he'll be back let's track it
[Music]
um
you got an email
in July like a group email
from Mark
just before July 4th
just after yeah
and
I want to read this email
um
Mark says this
glory is something that some men Chase
and others find themselves stumbling
upon not expecting it to find them
either way it is a noble gesture that
one finds bestowed upon them my question
is
when does glory fade away and become a
wrongful Crusade or an unjustified means
by which consumes one completely
I've seen one
I've seen death the sorrow that
encompasses your entire being as a man
breathes his last
I can only pray and hope that none of
you will ever have to experience some of
the things I have seen and felt here
I have felt fear
and it felt adrenaline pump through my
veins making me seem Invincible I will
be honest and say that some of the
things I've seen here are unjustified
and uncalled for
however for the most part we are helping
this country
it will take more years than most expect
but we will get Iraq to stand on its own
feet most of what I see what most of
what I have seen here will never I will
never really mention or speak of only
due to the nature of those involved
I've seen a man give his food to a
hungry child and family
today I saw a hospital that most of us
would refuse to receive treatment from
the filth and smell would allow most of
us to not be able to stand to enter let
alone get medicine from
however you will be relieved to know
that Coalition forces has started to
provide security for and Supply medicine
and equipment to help aid in the cause
I've seen amazing things happen here
however I've seen the sad part of war 2.
I've seen the morals of a man who cares
nothing of human life I have seen hate
towards a nation's people who has never
committed or wrong except being born of
a third world ill-educated and ignorant
to Western civilization
it is not everybody who feels this way
only a select few but it brings
questions to mind is it okay for one to
consider themselves Superior to another
race
surprisingly we are not a stranger to
this sort of attitude meaning that in
our own country we discriminate against
someone for what nationality they are
their education level their social
status we distinguish our role models as
multi-million dollar sports heroes or
talented actors and actresses who
complain about not getting millions of
dollars more than they are currently
getting paid
our country is a great country don't get
me wrong on this otherwise none of us
would be living there my point of this
is how can we come over here and help a
less than fortunate country without
holding contempt or hate towards them if
we can't do it in our country
I try to do my part over here but the
truth is over there in the United States
I do nothing but take
ask yourself when was the last time you
don't donated clothes that you hadn't
worn out
when was the last time you paid for
random stranger's cup of coffee meal or
even maybe a tank of gas
when was the last time you helped a
person with the groceries into or out of
their car
think to yourself and wonder what it
would feel like if when the bill for the
meal came and you were told it was
already paid for
more random acts of kindness like this
would change our country and our
reputation as a country
it is not unknown to most of us that the
rest of the world looks at us with doubt
towards our humanity and morals I am not
here to preach or to say look at me
because I am just as at fault as the
next person
I find that being here makes me realize
the great country we have and the
obligation we have to keep it that way
the fourth has just come and gone and I
received many emails thanking me for
helping America great keep America great
and free
I take no credit for the career path I
have chosen
I can only give it to those of you who
are reading this because each one of you
has contributed
to me and who I am
however what I do over here is only a
small percent of what keeps our country
great
I think the truth to our greatness
is each other
Purity morals and kindness
passed down to each generation through
example
so to all my family and friends
do me a favor and pass on the kindness
the love
precious gift of human life to each
other
so that when your children come into
contact with a great conflict that we
are now faced with here in Iraq that
they are people of humanity
of pure motives
of compassion
this is our real part
keep America free
happy fourth love you
Mark Lee
P.S
halfway through the deployment
can't wait to see all of your faces
was that an indicator of some of the
heaviness that was happening with Mark
yeah I think very much so um
you you listen to that letter and you
you see the transformation that happened
for mark what he saw over there what he
endured
the humbleness the reality to say oh my
gosh I'm not any different than the rest
of you when I was there all I did was
take
you know he realized
the blessings that we do have
and I can't I've never been able to get
through that letter without getting
choked up at the end where he says
halfway through the deployment
can't wait to see your faces
and I know one day I'll see him again
and he successfully completed his
mission he did what he was supposed to
do over there
but for us we're halfway through
deployment there's still something we're
here and we're supposed to do
and that was Mark's challenge but
there's I mean we could do a whole
podcast on dissect and just that letter
apart and what he talks in there talks
about the country in the great country
we have and the obligation we have to
keep it that way and you see so many
people coming into our country and
trying to change it into something else
you see people I've sent Colin
Kaepernick in that letter when he
wouldn't stand for the national anthem
or for the flag
and I was like yeah I was the national
anthem at the flag but um I said you
know Colin my son even talked about you
in his last letter home
you know multi-million dollar sports
figures complain and I said Mark stood
he didn't kneel he didn't sit he stood
for what he believed in this country
you know you need to stand for what you
believe in here if you want to make a
difference go do something to make a
difference of course we never saw him
impact anything there I'm like that red
stripe on that flag that represents my
son's blood you will not disrespect that
so many others that have given so much
you know he talks about the random acts
of kindness you know and that's kind of
how the foundation
you know not officially but that's how I
started doing those things to honor Mark
I could pay for a stranger's cup of
coffee I could pay for a meal tank of
gas back then wasn't as expensive as it
is now but I could do those things I
understood
the price that was being paid and
sacrifices were made for me that's a
pretty simple thing to go up and say hey
I'm going to buy your coffee thank you
you know let me buy your tank of gas let
me buy your meal
you know it talks about opening a door
for you know someone or helping them
with their groceries in or out of their
car what's happened to America that
we've gotten so far away from that
you know and to end that with to my
family and friends do me a favor
pass on the kindness the love
precious gift of human life
we understand that precious gift and how
quickly it can be gone
but holy cow is America what's happened
to us why can't we pass on that kindness
we can have different opinions that's
what you guys fought for so we could
have those different opinions
but that doesn't mean you need to be so
mean and hateful to people
and I just really think some of those
things basically if we did those as
humans that Mark challenged us to do
we'd be living in a different world
and you know when I first got that like
I said it came as an email it was about
two weeks before he died and that wasn't
supposed to be the if you're reading
this I'm gone
and I read through it on the computer
and I was like who wrote this
and you know Mark was not stupid by any
means but language I had not seen that
as a strength or you know his Forte
and so I scrolled back to the top to see
who sent the email I'm like dang you
know that was Mark
and you just feel the changes
that took place and not just his mind
and his heart
and after he passed man then that letter
was even more significant
the meaning of that and the impact and
literally Jaco I don't millions and
millions of Lies have been changed by
Mark
I never would have thought when I held
him as a little baby in the midst of all
those struggles like I said I didn't
have high goals for him nobody's
pregnant nobody's now calling nobody's
drug addict at 18 I'm good
and to see that
but that came through the struggles that
came through
the perseverance of what we went through
and those are the things that molds us
and shape us
you know and what he saw over there
you know he's talking about Saddam about
you know the man who cares nothing you
know about moral life
and on my first trip over I was at biop
which is in
um Baghdad which is the main base there
for you guys and there's a lot of
saddam's palaces and the one of the
Palaces there was where he would have
his way you know with a virgin and then
he'd either behead them or throw them
off the balcony
and then he'd put a heart on the lattice
to remember them by him like what kind
of sick person does something like that
you know and obviously he didn't care
about human life he had no morals you
know he put all the waterways around his
palaces because he figured that you know
Allah wouldn't be able to see his sin if
he you know put the water around him
like well you don't think you're God's
big enough to look right down at what
you're doing
but there's some evil evil stuff in this
world
and that we've got men like Mark men
like you so many others that are willing
to confront that evil that most of us in
America have never even seen
or hopefully never will see Mark talks
about that you know
and it's just
amazing you know you talked about his
humor and who he was
yeah what a caring
compassionate and his words words of
wisdom Way Beyond his 28 years
most of it takes a lifetime
to get that
you know it just
I would encourage everybody that's
listening to go to our website you can
read that on our website at America's
mightywarriors.org
powerful powerful letter
um
August 2nd
and this is what I
kind of covered in the opening of this
podcast
you know the guys are out they're doing
a clearance this is
this was just a daily basis doing big
clearances supporting big big clearances
Ryan gets wounded and and you know
it seemed like Ryan may die
um
he he was I mean he's shot in the face I
mean it's it's horrible
when that happens
um you know it's on a rooftop
and
it's a single shot boom and what does
Mark do Mark steps right into where Ryan
was to lay down suppressive fire so the
guys can get to
so the Corman can get up there and get
Ryan to cover and start getting worked
on so like out of the gate this is this
is just what this is what Mark is doing
um
they get Ryan evacuated and again I'm
talking to life and life was not
optimistic
and
they
they go back to combat Outpost Falcon
and this is this is life and later too
this is Charleston so it's late if it's
BTF Tony Chris Kyle Kevin lace is there
uh Jason Hogan and there's a bunch of
other guys obviously
um
but a bunch of great guys they're all
you know they're obviously they're
worried about
uh Ryan and everything
and when this happens
with Ryan and these guys go back to
combat Outpost Falcon
um
you know that the army goes out and they
go they start going hard and it's Mike
baima and the he's the company Commander
from the 137 from the bandits and they
go out and they start meeting really
Fierce resistance
and they eventually find some buildings
like where they think they've got the
enemy
um
they ask life like hey can you can you
guys come out and hit some of these
buildings and that's when they've called
me and he's like hey the Iraqis aren't
going the Iraqis are too scared we're
going I'm like Roger
um
you know this is again this is what I
read in the beginning I'm watching the
Bradleys go out
um
seeing them hit the first uh buildings
and then they moved to this other
building and it actually one of uh the
assistant platoon commanders a great guy
um under lathe
I remember talking to him and he like as
they pull up to the second building
there's they're in a Bradley Fighting
Vehicle and there's rounds hitting the
Bradley Fighting Vehicle and and
this assistant platoon Commander is
trying to yell
to the tank to The Bradley crew don't
open the door he's like trying to get
their attention and it's too loud and
they just open the door and so then what
do you do you go and that's what they
did
um
and you know it opened they assaulted
the building
um
once they're in the building you know
there's there's stairs going up they're
taking fire and and
Mark instead of taking cover instead of
hiding he he steps out into the line of
fire to protect his brothers
and
you know he's killed
um
this is all taking place
the morning of August 2nd in Iraq so
back here it's 11 hours ahead in Iraq so
it's probably late at night here
um
you're you're probably at least going to
bed or you're getting ready to go to bed
and going to sleep
what are you doing what were you doing
on August 2nd when you wake up in the
morning what what's going on there's a I
know that from our perspective I
mentioned that you know when someone
gets killed you immediately stop all
Communications because
the the they want the notification
process to take place and you don't want
to get to the news you don't definitely
don't want someone some family member to
be watching the news so it's a race
what are you doing on August 2nd
anyway I don't remember when I woke up
that morning what I was doing but
um I know that there was and I know Mark
had changed the paperwork I had moved
from Oregon where I raised them pretty
much down to Arizona and I know he'd
call and got the new address and new
information as he was updating his
paperwork before he left
but for whatever reason they were trying
to find me up in Oregon
where I'd lived
and um you know we stand in the the seal
Community we send our own caico group up
there so that group was up in Oregon
and the building you know where I lived
I still own but um there wasn't it was
empty and they had been there for about
eight hours trying to find finally they
knocked on one of the neighbors and they
said she doesn't live here anymore she
lives down in Arizona
so this is the evening by that point and
they like you said they're afraid I'm
going to find out on the news
so they called Luke Air Force Base isn't
too far from me so they called there and
they had a small Detachment of Navy
that's there and sent out the Navy caico
officer and a chaplain
and I was gone that night I was actually
at my Bible study at my small group
and they waited for a while and then
knocked on the neighbor's door and her
husband had served in the military so
she kind of had a clue of what was going
on she didn't have my cell phone number
didn't know how to get a hold of me
and she said well I know Debbie's son
works at Lowe's you know the Lowe's just
down the street
so they called Christopher
and again he served in the Marines you
know
when they show up at your house it's not
good if Mark had been wounded you know
they'd got word to us and got us to him
and so
oddly enough we were celebrating my
birthday that night we hadn't met the
week before which my birthday was the
Wednesday before Mark died on a
Wednesday
and uh
we'd had missionaries that were there
speaking to our small group and they're
telling the story about Cuba and I think
it was his brother-in-law
and how you know they had been captured
for being a spy or something and two
guys showed up at the Y store and
knocked on the door and said you need to
grab your children and come with us if
you want to see your husband again
and as they go through the story it ends
up it's Navy Seals
like oh my son's an evco you know he's
he's in ramadi
of course that point he'd already passed
but um
we got done we're celebrating my
birthday and my girlfriend gave me one
of those willow tree angels and those
are the wooden angels with the wire
wings
and each one usually has a character
quality and the one she gave me was
courage
and this is before we found out about
Mark and she just said with all you've
been through in your life you just
remind me of such a woman of Courage you
still are positive you still serve God
you're not a negative person you're not
a hateful person
and little did we know how much more
courage was going to be required in the
next half hour
and I always turn my phone off that
night I hadn't and Christopher called
nothing in his voice to alert me he
wasn't speaking too fast he wasn't
crying
he's like hey Mom where are you
it's Wednesday night and that my Bible
study why what's up
he said how long will it take you to get
home
oh that's well that's odd question I
said I don't know five minutes seven
minutes why what's up
and he said you just need to come home
and I knew I knew at that point
what was going to face me when I got
home
and I grabbed my purse and I just told
everybody please be praying something's
not right
and I got my car and there was a song
from my past and it says I put my hope
in You O Lord trusting you I will not be
shaken knowing that you will see me
through I put my hope in you and I just
sang that over and over and over and
over
and I got to the main intersection by my
house and there was probably three or
four fire trucks and a couple police
cars and ambulances and I'm like my
house blew up that's all that's wrong
and trust me I would have rather lost
all my worldly possessions and still had
Mark and to this day I have no idea how
I got through that intersection but I
got back into my subdivision there are
no more emergency vehicles so I went
back to I know it's going to face me
when I get home
and as I turned the corner I expected to
see a black car
parked there I guess I've watched too
many movies but there was no black car
there was no unusual car they'd parked
down the street aways
and my oldest son Christopher was just
pacing back and forth on the sidewalk
and he said Mom the Navy's here
and I remember just putting my whole
head on his shoulder
crying saying no no
we walked in the house and of course
they'd been in my house for a little bit
because they were trying to find me I
guess I could be elusive at times
and uh
they said we can tell by being in your
home your woman of faith you need to
rely on your faith for what we're about
to tell you
your son Mark Allen Lee
has been guilt in action
as you can imagine the most devastating
word you could ever hear as a parent
and yet even at that moment
I knew I knew where my strength was
going to come from I knew that God was
going to see me through
I knew this would be much harder than
losing my husband
but I knew he would see me through
and my circumstances had drastically
changed that day
but my god did not he was still the same
God on August 2nd as he was on August
1st his character hadn't changed
and we went and sat on the couch and
I've got a skinny window next to my door
did in the other house that I lived in
at the time and I looked outside and my
friends were from my small group were
all standing outside I'm like what the
heck get in here I need you in here
and um The Neighbor Next Door was from
New York very proper and he's like oh no
you don't go in there you give them time
and so they came in and
we just talked about Mark and tried to
process it and we cried and prayed and
cried and cried
they stayed for a couple hours and
it was probably about 11 o'clock and
everybody had left
my son Christopher was still there he
served in the Marines he was in Okinawa
for five years or Plus
met his wife over there and
she before they had five kids would go
home every year for six weeks
and he my daughter and my
daughter-in-law had both just lost
babies the year before five and a half
months in their pregnancy which is
pretty unusually use it lose a child
that far along
and of course our first thought was oh
no no more loss no more babies they were
just both three months in their
pregnancy and so he had decided to
protect her to not tell her what was
going on he knew that she'd be back home
before the funeral and how
he did that
struggling with probably the toughest
pain he's ever known and not tell his
wife and carry on conversations is
beyond me but
he said Mom I'm going to stay here
tonight I said thank you son
he said I'm going to try to get some
sleep I'm like okay well I knew and
there was no way sleep was coming to me
and I just wanted somebody to hold me
and tell me it's gonna be okay we'll get
through this
at that point I've been a widow for 12
years and so there was nobody there
and I remember thinking okay
God's promise to be a husband of the
Widow and a father to the fatherless I
know where my strength is going to come
and so I went and grabbed my Bible and
just opened it and opened to Psalms 27
that's right where it plopped open it
said the Lord is my light and my
salvation Whom Shall I Fear the Lord is
the strength of my life of whom shall I
be afraid
when the wicked came against me to eat
up my flesh my enemies and my foes they
stumbled and they fell
though an army may rise against me I
will not fear
the war may come against me and I read
that going oh my goodness did did you
write this today for me for my first
circumstances
and the end of it says I would have lost
hope
if I'd not believed I'd see the goodness
of the Lord in the land of the living
wait on the Lord
be of good courage
and I will strengthen your heart wait I
stand Lord and I close my Bible I saw
that courage thing again I got the
courage Angel at the beginning of the
night and now God's reminding me again
courage I'm like I got it Lord
and as I sat there and was praying I've
never audibly heard God speak but in my
thoughts he said
I want you to read this at Mark's
funeral
I want you to give everybody else the
same hope
that I've given you
as I said I was a rebel in my 20s only
teenagers too
you know God says he said hate seven
things and I'd done six of them I was
faithful in my marriage you can go read
the rest of them I don't want to get
into all that but
I've learned that if he asked me to do
something
to just obey and do it it may not make
any sense he tells us his ways are not
our ways
but I'm sure I kind of was like a
teenager and kind of went ah
are you kidding me God
that's my son's funeral I don't know if
I'll throw up or pass out I don't know
what I'll do
and I pause and I say I will walk
through whatever doors you open thinking
it just meant to speak at Mark's funeral
I know that if God would have told me
what he had in store and all the
different places that I'd be at one
point I spoke in front of a million
people on the wall the mall in
Washington DC
and I was terrified terrified to speak
in front of people with the preschool in
kindergarten we had two programs a year
one at Christmas and one at the
kindergarten graduation I would
literally hold the microphone with both
hands and it'd still be bouncing all
over because I was terrified to be in
front of people so this was not my
comfort zone this wasn't something I'm
like oh yeah I'm such a great speaker uh
yeah this would be awesome I'm like okay
and um
to see what he's done and the toughest
thing that I could go through in life
and how he's taken that
taken Marx Roy's his story to continue
to impact people and change the world
is nothing but a miracle you know but
again
the toughest pain I've ever known you
know you can't
um
avoid pain you've got to walk right
through the middle of it you can't go
around it over it
you can't get stuck in it because then
you don't heal you don't get to the the
healthier side
but all the reading I've done on Grief
that said that's the toughest thing you
could ever go through is the instant
death of a child
and I would have to agree with that you
know granted my husband wasn't the love
of my life that I've been married to for
50 years but
whoo
much tougher much tougher but
so proud of Mark
um
I look forward to that day when I do get
to see him again give him another big
hug you know kick him in the butt and
say okay why did you not tell us you
were married
but um
if I know anything I know God doesn't
waste pain
you know if we allow him he will take
that and use that for his glory
and you know in his wisdom he doesn't
have him be I'm not flying planes going
oh well yeah it's yeah it's just because
I'm so good at this that's why it's
working it's like no no you don't
understand I don't have any skills or
talents to be a public speaker never
taking classes on it you know it's just
going through that life experience
and really what am I going to be afraid
of Mark ran into the line of fire
how many times just on his final day I'm
gonna be afraid of speaking in front of
people yeah I don't think so
so
the as I mentioned in the beginning
um you know basically as soon as we
found out that you had been notified you
know we get the word and then guys start
calling
calling you to talk to you and it's
actually all happening from I I have an
office in the Tactical operations center
with the direct landline to America and
so guys are coming in
calling from there and
again our attitude was we're going to
have to be consoling you know Mark's mom
and it was literally the opposite it was
literally the opposite
you know it was my guys that needed
consoling you were the one that was
saying you know what do you need what
can I send you what do you how can I
help you guys
and I mean so it was like this courage
that you
had gotten uh the the message on you
immediately put into action
um
and then it was just um
for us
to be able to to talk to you the guys
talking to you and
um
hearing your voice and your
encouragement is what allowed guys to be
able to say okay you know we can move
forward
and and
you know that scene of comp coming out
of Charlie mad
and seeing all those soldiers and
Marines just lined up and
you know that's like
sometimes people will attempt to bait me
into saying something negative about the
army of the Marine Corps and they can't
do it yeah
um
nothing but love for those guys
when did you
so we sent guys home guys came home with
Mark you know guys escorted Mark home
when when did you start meeting the guys
from the task unit from Charlie platoon
from tasking to Bruiser
um and it was excuse me
um I think it was
the majority of you guys it was when you
came back from that deployment
uh I
yesterday we were at the funeral and I
was like
spoke at Mark's funeral I'm like how can
you not remember
your son's ceremony and who spoke and I
remember being in another one in the
same it was at the chapel there on on
North Island I remember being later at
another funeral there I'm like did we
have Mark's gasket in here I don't
remember I'm like but I think just part
of that it's too much so you just don't
remember it
so I don't I know Bobby gasoff
at first that was his Mark swim buddy
and yeah man that's a pretty tight
connection with your swim buddy
and they weren't going to send him at
first because they said no he's in too
much pain this is not who we send and of
course now they've learned that that is
and um they said Commodore palibos at
the time at now Admiral pivas was on our
doorstep the next morning
and uh you you know Sean you know what a
compassionate
caring man and again I still don't even
at that point didn't understand the
ranks I knew Admiral was something
special but
but an admiral showed up on my doorstep
granted he was Commodore would he have
been an admiral as the Commodore yeah no
that's okay he's a captain I always had
the hardest time with the Commodore
thing I'm like yeah and it's a position
it's a position not a rank yeah
but he was there at the door uh
and I remember them saying what else can
we do for you I'm like give me Bobby
gasoff I want Bobby here
and so they did get Bobby home
I think he might have been in the
Philippines at the time he stayed with
me he and his wife stayed with us for a
week
but I don't even remember who the other
one was I know later that Brian yarbo
has told me he was one of them that
escorted Mark home
let's say it was Jason Hogan the other
one or do you remember I think so yeah
we sent a few it was a few guys it was a
few guys we sent home yeah
um and and then obviously we sent guys
home with Mike too and when guys came
home with Mikey they were coming home
like we knew that they weren't coming
back because it was the end of
deployment right so I can't remember
exactly which guys went with who with
Mark and which guys went with Mikey
um
because some of them came back no it was
pretty close so it's only seven seven
and a half weeks but I think the
majority of that started uh by phone
calls and emails while you guys were
still deployed
you know um I remember thinking oh my
gosh I can't make any decisions my brain
is mush
holy cow those guys are in combat
they've got life or death decision
they've stuck gotta make and once I
realized having Marx Brothers in our
home for the week
wow you guys love Mark as much as we did
and you were hurting Justice and that's
like oh the Brotherhood thing I got it
now it makes sense
and so my concern for you guys is you're
in that combat zone you're still going
out on patrol
man how are you guys going to deal with
this how are you guys going to process
and stay safe
you know and you you know I think it was
life was the one I'm like you guys go
back out there you you go get some you
know don't don't hang in your rooms and
you know Mark would want you to continue
the mission
but
that's really when those relationships
started I got a copy of the Charlie
Batoon picture
and I'd say okay who's the one on the
left and I'd write the name down okay
the tall guy in the middle who's that
and of course they gave me their name
names
and then they talk about Biff or I'm
like I don't I'm gonna have a Biff on
the sheets who's Biff you know and then
I learned okay most of them have other
names that they they go by but and I get
phone calls even from some of the moms
of the guys you know checking on me and
I knew
I didn't know I was going to start a
foundation
but we had a lot of support up to the
funeral and now I live in Arizona I'm
not near a base I'm not here you know
San Diego where
you know the rest of the community is a
major part of it
but once funeral's over there was
nothing I mean other than talking to you
guys over there it just
you know it stopped
and I'm like oh crud well it's just
starting for me now the process the
Journey of grief is just starting and
I've never been one to feel sorry for
myself
I was like okay I can't change anything
you think for myself but I can change it
so nobody else has to go through without
having support there somebody that knows
what it's like
so when I got the call
that Mikey had died I knew I had to be
there I didn't know what I was going to
do but I just knew I had to be there
and then that was about the time
you know the first ones were starting to
come back home and I'm like man I got to
be there for my boys not to be oh my
gosh there's poor Mark's mom but to say
woohoo the rest of my boys are home you
know thank you thank you and
um
you know so was here and then came over
for the funeral I remember coming over
and it was the same hotel or they'd put
us up for Mark's funeral
same black vehicles I don't know exact
same but you know that black SUV that
you guys have and I was standing down
there that morning
um given you know Sally and the family
big hugs and
said I'm so sorry
and uh
Admiral McGuire came down and
ask how I was doing let's go hang it in
there
and he said um we want you to go in the
vehicle with the family I'm like oh no
no no no I'm not here this is not that
bark this is not not about me at all I'm
just here to support the family and they
said exactly you know and and almost a
panic
you know here we got another one you
know we thought we were good for a while
and now seven weeks later we got another
one
and he said exactly that's why we want
you in the vehicle to support them I'm
like okay
so now I'm in the vehicle reliving
going back up to Fort Rosecrans same
casket Mark was buried in
same place although now I know what it's
like to get the folded flag I know what
it's been to be done with the funeral
and start that grieving process I
manages you know the little bit of the
wound that was starting to heal was now
ripping open
but still I knew it was the right thing
I knew that's where it's supposed to be
to support this family just to be there
I didn't have anything planned I didn't
you know just to be there and that's why
I tell people all the time when
someone's grieving
just be there don't worry about what you
should say what you shouldn't say should
I take anything should I not take
anything just be there it means so much
to have someone else there
with you if they want to talk about it
they'll probably open up and start
talking about it you don't need to worry
you know it's not like I don't remember
that you know I had a son Mark and what
happened to him
but it's so important to be there and
that was really
the first family that we supported you
know we got pretty close to the Monsour
family and
um
you know Sally just passed away a couple
months ago and so we were there again
you know to be able to support and honor
Mikey but because I love that family
I understand their sacrifice and that's
really what started
the America's Mighty Warriors process
thinking and then I would just happen to
be in Washington DC when Jay Redmond was
there you know before even the note was
posted on the door of you know don't
feel sorry for me if you're coming in
here to feel sorry for me I earned these
wounds doing what I you know love doing
and don't I don't need your sympathy
I was in the hospital when Dan Knutson
was brought down from surgery I just
happened to be in Washington DC
so these things just kept happening
that is my spiritual gift is to be an
encourager and you know to support
people
and so that's where
my strength that's where I work well
when I'm doing those things
and then after a while I'm like ah okay
I get it I think there's a mission ahead
I don't think I'm just supposed to do
this once or twice
and um you know that's when I'm like
okay I can't continue to afford to fund
this on my own time so we really do need
to so officially we started the
foundation
in 2008 but um and the name of it
America's Mighty Warriors the meaning of
the name mark means mighty warrior
you know he definitely lived up to his
name didn't you get that name from like
a menu or something great is that it did
Mark put that in your head to tell me
that somebody is always like a long time
he's always like great you got my name
from a menu Mom that's what it is right
and it was it was from a menu as I
mentioned I'd already gone through the
divorce I was by myself here I'm having
this baby I have a three and a half year
old two-year-old and now another little
one of course back then you stayed three
days in the hospital that was
common if it was rare that they let you
go before that and they always ask
do you have small children and do you
have help
like yes I have small children no I have
no help
and um
I I knew that they heard two heartbeats
I knew that I knew that I knew I was
having twin girls so I had names picked
out for girls but no boy names
and they came in the day after he was
born and said you've got to go home we
need your bed
smokes and they're like sorry
so they said you've got to name the baby
before you go home and
no one to discuss it with no one to
figure it out and he was born in March I
looked down at the menu for the day that
was on my tray table and the H was
covered up and I saw Marc
being a Debbie everybody in my era at
least half the world I think was named
Debbie we were cheerleaders 10 of us
five of us were named Debbie
and you'd say Debbie and half the hall
would go huh you know and I'm like I
don't want that for my kids I want them
to have an individual name but that was
also in the hippie era so you're getting
some really funky names that they were
naming their kids and I didn't want them
to have weird names
leave that to me but
um so when I saw Mark with the Seekers
back then everybody was spelling Mark
with a k
and I did not know at the time it meant
mighty warrior but that's where the name
of our foundation is America's Mighty
Warriors because it's not just about
Mark obviously marks the story We Tell
marks the reason that we do what we do
but it's about every man and woman who
served it's about every other family
who's lost a loved one you know and
that's
been you know a lot of work a lot of
challenges but man what a blessing what
a reward to be able to
have that relationship I had a call from
one of the other guys the team guy that
were helping haven't heard from him for
a while and he goes I don't know you
well it wasn't any Mark's teammates you
know they're really close ones
but there's something unique
about
my relationship with even ones that I
first meet you know and he said he's
having some struggles he said you were
the first one I thought of to be able to
reach out to
and that God has given me that blessing
that honor to be able to be there and to
understand and give you guys hope and
encouragement now I'm not going to baby
you
if you think you're coming to homily oh
I'm so sorry you poor little guy why
don't you why don't you go lay down
again no I'm gonna listen I'm gonna hear
you out I'm gonna validate it but then
I'm going to say get your butt up here's
what you need to do you know lovingly
but you guys don't need somebody
pampering a baby and you guys that's not
who you are
you know and um
I will do that you know until God gives
me my final breath to be able to
continue to support you guys and be
there for you and
so you started it in 2008 officially
with the IRS yes that's when you went
through all that process
and then
I mean it's
September 2009 is when when we lost Ryan
and that that was like um
so unexpected
and you know we kind of thought like
you're beyond you think you're okay
you're home yeah just it's not gonna
happen you're home you're safe same
thing with Chris same thing with Seth
you know you're just like
wait he did all those paddles Ryan
survived like you said a lot of the guys
said they didn't think there was any way
he could survive those wounds he did he
thrived he didn't just survive you know
I've got still a pound of the elk meat
in my freezer that I'll never eat from
the elk that he went out shot as a blind
person
you know he had he had you know just
completed I don't know if it's his
bachelor's or his Masters yeah that he
just completed you know yeah exactly he
called we all found this out later
everybody's saying guess what I'm gonna
be a daddy but don't say anything
because I'm not supposed to tell anybody
but he called everybody who told
everybody
um yeah and just
so
so tragic it didn't have to be
you know
and then um and then it was like
Chris yeah which again is just so out of
so uh totally unexpected yeah
and and I know you you would become
really close with Chris yeah
um
you know as
CR obviously Chris being such a a
legendary figure and how he's portrayed
all the time and and you know whenever
I'm talking to someone like like
personally talking to someone that wants
to know about Chris
if I know them for you know having a
conversation with a little more depth
you know the one story I always tell
people about Chris is
that when at the memorial service we did
for Mark
in ramadi
like you know guys got up and talked and
you know read things or you know told
little anecdotal stories about Mark
and like Chris couldn't do it and and
when we got done like he was CR he was
crying so hard and he was apologizing to
me he's like I'm sorry he was just
breaking down he just he just couldn't
do it and and that's you know that's I
know that it doesn't get portrayed that
way
um but that's that's that was Chris like
Chris
just was heartbroken yeah
and and I know that he had become really
close with you
um and yeah then so that just was
another just completely and utterly
unexpected
well and it was I had a more physical
violent reaction when I found out about
Chris than I did with Mark
um obviously my pain was much more
intense for Mark my son
but I actually threw up and I was
freaked out I'm just like and um I had
found out
um that he probably had been killed
before his wife had had did and I knew I
just talked to her and she didn't know
and so then I'm you know they're like
we're in route we're in route we're
going to tell her but it was just like
another one
you know and um I thought about that and
I thought
this is so painful you know how much of
this can you endure and as I thought
about that I'm like okay well the other
option is
not to have known you guys not to have
been close to you I'm like nope that's
not an option this is just part of what
comes along when you love people
and sometimes the grief is you know
part of that love you know that you you
cared for him and Chris and I had just
been at Shot Show we were trying to
Rebrand him he wasn't taking any money
from the book he'd started his um
tactical company craft he was paying his
staff but he still wasn't making much
from them so we were trying to Rebrand
him
you know so he could have some regular
money coming in for him
and it was amazing time uh so many great
memories you know from those four days
that we were
there together and then just two weeks
later he's gone
you know and it's just like and again
he survived how many deployments did he
do
and he'd come home and some
nut job I mean people have tried to in
the media portray that as the guy that
shot him had pts and this was because of
war no
the the guy was messed up before he
tried killing a family member as a
teenager
and his family to protect him didn't you
know report that to the police
and Chris you know Chris had a huge
heart that was where you know his kids
went to school the mother the guy that
killed him was you know one of the aides
and one of his kids class and she just
said hey he's really struggling since he
came back you know
from his deployment do you think you
could help him
man I I hold her culpable for not
sharing the extent of that because Chris
would have done something else he still
would have helped him but he'd have done
something else that day
and the guy wasn't you know
far enough gone he knew what he was
doing you know he waited till they'd
fired all their ammunition
Chris had holstered his weapon he shot
Chris first and then
his buddy Chad and
then he went and got a taco before he
went to his sister's house I'm like oh
my gosh
so yeah and you know the I know we've
talked about this before Jocko but I'm
like Chris's mom's name was Debbie
my name's Debbie Seth is Mom's Debbie
so I'm like if you're on Charlie between
your mom's name's Debbie please go tell
her to change her name
you know but it's just um
so much is given
and yet so much was required
so you obviously um
you know you you and I unfortunately
have been through all these things and
you've been with them with with all of
us
and you're
you're
um
reaction to these things is is America's
Mighty Warriors that's what you do
because you know that the pain and the
loss isn't limited to us it's there's
all kinds of people that
you know anybody that served has gone
through these kind of things
with a little bit more detail on
America's Mighty Warriors because I know
what you do I have friends that have
been pulled out of the depths of Hell
from what you do
can you just give us some of the high
level like you got veteran advocacy so
what is it what does that mean so and
play that was Stronger when you guys
were still in combat right any issues
that there were for our veterans we're
going to stand up and change this we're
going to make it right but like you've
gone to DC you've talked about you have
relationships with people you can call
people yep got great connections there
um I don't know if you remember back in
you might have been deployed then but
Delta Airlines I think it was 2008 they
were charging our troops coming back
from the combat zone excess baggage fees
and I'm like oh come on no that that
can't really be true and I've never been
one just to react
I'm going to verify just because it's on
the internet don't believe it and so I
called Delta Airlines and I just said
you know I understand that you guys are
charging our service members who are
coming back excess baggage fees yes
that's our policy that's correct
I said well you do understand They're
bringing back their weapons that they've
used to defend you and your freedom
you know it's not like they went RNR and
they're bringing Turkish rugs back home
and she said yes ma'am we understand
that I said well
you really need to refund that money to
them well that's not our policy we're
not going to do that I said well
I've got a pretty big you know following
an outrage if you don't refund that to
them then I'm going to let people know
the details I'm going to give them your
phone numbers your emails
I said okay fine
within 48 hours they had reversed their
decision and we're refunding the money
because people were canceling their you
know frequent flyers with Delta they
canceled their flights and
obviously it wasn't just me you know it
was this fear of influence you know that
God's placed around me to help do that
but the one voice
one person can make a difference
the other one was um and I can't even
remember who was The Joint Chiefs of
Staff when
um the Isis flag went back up over
ramadi
and man
he got on there and said there's no
significance to that
and I'm like
I felt like somebody literally had
sucker punched me I'm like are you
kidding me right now my son's blood is
on that soil don't tell me that's not
significance that the enemy flags flying
up there again
and as we know you know as ramadi goes
so goes the rest of Iraq
and so again I'm like okay called The
Pentagon I wanted his address and they
gave me the main address for the
Pentagon I'm like I wasn't born
yesterday he has an address where his
mail goes I'm not going to send this
where you get millions of pieces of mail
a day could I please have his address to
send that to him
and they said no here's the address I'm
like okay so I mailed it off but then I
sent out to my media contacts
and
um I got a call Saturday morning from
his Pao and he said um
ma'am we understand that you've demanded
an apology
from The Joint Chiefs of Staff
I said yes and I said not just for me
it's every other man and woman who
served there it's every other you know
veteran who left a body part behind
there it's every other family who's lost
a loved one there you should know better
than anybody else how powerful your
words are and what that meant
he said why won't you know you know he
carries in his pocket jacket the names
of the fallen and he rotates that out
I'm like great then he's gonna have no
problem apologizing
and he goes well ma'am that's not
again for three days I did you know
National media
and um even CNN and they had done a
great great interview like eight minute
interview which is pretty long when
you're doing National media
and I just got off Lou Dobbs show on
um
on Fox and was in the car coming back
home
and I had looked at um
Facebook I had a message
because they called the office but I
wasn't there and they're trying to reach
me right away and they you know said
please call whatever the pao's name was
and he said
we'd just like you to know that you
you'll be receiving an apology letter
and he wants to personally speak with
you
and I got home and my son Christopher
and one of his buddies were there
already and I was like oh my gosh and my
daughter-in-law being from Japan you
know she's like okay so he apologized
what's the big deal and my son's like
well he's in charge of the army the Navy
the Marine Corps you know the Air Force
and um
again I don't ever want to be Cindy
Sheehan was you know out there and
protesting against the troops you know
before Mark died
she ended up losing her son who believed
in the mission who believed what he was
doing just like Mark did and how you can
take an opposite stand to me that's
disrespectful to your loved one who gave
their life you can have a different
opinion but astronaut how you honor them
and I never want to be you know like she
was I always wanted to make sure I
honored and respected Mark and
everything that I did and that I don't
ever do anything to dishonor him or his
name or his sacrifice
you know and she was pretty wackadoodle
in some of her tactics that was the um
Medea Benjamin and what was that code
pink
confronted them numerous times in in DC
but um you know just passionate about
making sure that you guys get what
you're entitled to you know Rules of
Engagement back then were pretty bad so
we worked on that our random acts of
kindness that Mark talks about we
started with the coffee meals tank of
gas and do those often you know thank
you Mark for leaving that because on
those tough days that's what I go do
and it really changes things you know
when I go to an Air Force Base or going
to Village Inn and see the you know
Vietnam veteran hats or whatever and you
go up and you do that for them and it
you know it really makes a difference in
the last time and they're like no I'm
good ma'am I'm like no no you don't
understand my son's last let her home
challenge made me do that yes ma'am yes
ma'am but um and we expanded that
program it goes up to a five thousand
dollar Grant
so um just this last week we had two
different seal families and we do all
branches in the military obviously the
seal communities my family so you know
we do a lot for for them but had
circumstances that we were able to help
with a five thousand dollar check for
each family
um you know that the veteran can't come
ask because there are veterans
unfortunately are just going from
charity to charity to see what they can
take you know and that's not who we want
to help so you know you could reach out
and say you know hey here's the
circumstance you know their child has
cancer and you know they need somebody
to take care of their other kids while
they're in the hospital all the time or
you know unfortunately we do a lot of
funeral expenses
um
but those are huge that lets somebody
know they're not alone in the midst of
that
we do our Gold Star Family program so
yeah the gold star Retreats that you do
we do those in Texas
um we've been doing those for 12 years
and again my philosophy on grieving is
it needs to be natural don't force me if
I'm having a good day please don't put
me in a circle with 20 other gold star
moms and we're all telling our loved one
story we're all going to be blubbering
idiots you know when we get done
if if we're sitting at a table or
sharing a meal and you want to say hey
what do you do on his anniversary you
know how do you handle the birthday is
this feeling normal for you you know
it's natural you've got a choice whether
you participate or not you know again
there's swimming pools there's kayaking
there's zip lining paddle boarding one
time I accidentally said we're
waterboarding and they're like oh no
sorry but bring the Terrace here I got
no problem waterboarding them but um we
have a house in Arizona called the
heroes hope home and one in Florida
called The Serenity hope home where they
can come stay free for a week we take
care of their flights their rental car
everything and just love and pamper on
them let them know we won't forget your
hero and we won't forget you
our biggest program right now is our
helping hero CEO program right and
that's for our veterans combat veterans
who are diagnosed with traumatic brain
injury post-traumatic stress
many of them suicidal now we're paying
for hyperbaric oxygen therapy hormone
and supplement therapy natural things
that are actually healing them there's
so many things out there that are just
masking the symptoms
and I get it I really do understand why
they want to try anything and everything
to get rid of the pain whether it's
physical mental spiritual all the above
I get that
but let's try things that are proven to
heal you we've been doing spec scans of
the brain before and after
and to see those is just phenomenal some
of them I see them the first time before
they go through the treatment I'm like
how are you even functioning I mean
literally it looks like an RPG went
through their head there's just part of
it that there's not getting any Oxygen
to it
and then to see that contrasting scan
afterwards and to hear their stories and
I remember it's probably been about four
years ago now but we had another Navy
SEAL who'd gone through the program and
I called to just check and see what
symptoms are different you know what'd
you notice because everybody heals
differently everybody has a different
extent of their injuries and he went
through the things that were better and
like that's awesome he goes you saved my
life and I said well you were willing to
give your life for me this literally is
a no-brainer that I would do this for
you
and he paused and he said stop I'm like
made an ABC old man this is not going to
end well he goes I wouldn't be alive
today if it wasn't for you and your
foundation and the therapies you
provided you saved my life
and when he said it that strong I
thought a mark
spinal actions standing up in the line
of fire to save his teammates and I was
like
oh my gosh he's still saving his
teammates he's not physically here but
he's still saving his teammates
and so to see that impact
you know to continue to be even if there
were only one time mission accomplished
WooHoo but to see that continue to
happen over and over and over and
you know I know yesterday as we're at
the funeral there's you know so many
more of our guys that this um has caused
things to surface in them
and I probably had at least 10 yesterday
that were like we need help Mama Lee I'm
like here here's my card send me your
email we'll get you an application we'll
get things going
and on average the cost is twenty
thousand dollars for them to go through
a year-long program last year we had 175
guys in our program and gals we do both
branches I see guys kind of generically
but including our women because we have
some amazing female veterans that need
help as well
but
to have
that opportunity to see that impact
you know that God allowed me to be able
to do that and to be able to
continue to meet so many of our amazing
Warriors who give so much and their
families
you know it really is a blessing but you
know it's not cheap to provide those
Therapies
and I just really want to encourage any
of you guys and gals that are listening
who served if you aren't diagnosed with
TBI or pts or you're struggling with
suicide please please reach out I know
that you get to that place where you
feel like there's no hope you've tried
different therapies that maybe haven't
worked and you feel like this is how I'm
going to have to live the rest of my
life
and it doesn't have to be that way
they're actually physical things that
are happening to the frontal lobe of
your brain to other parts of your brain
from the blast wave exposure that
affects your memory that affects your
sleep there's parts of your brain a
rational decision making
and there's things that we can do to
heal that so please that is not a sign
of weakness to ask for help that takes
courage that takes strength you're being
a leader to be able to do that so please
reach out to us
um
my husband committed suicide 28 years
ago
so that's another thing that we've lived
through that gives us the ability you're
not going to say anything that's going
to freak me out or scare me or cause me
to react irrationally
I'm gonna be there to give you hope to
listen to you to encourage you
and let you know in that healing process
where you're at
and we've we've suffered too many losses
and it's got to stop it's got to start
a different attitude you know at the
Head Shed and our our different branches
of the military
you know I tell them if you washed your
leg in combat you wouldn't be like Oh
I'm good I got this I'm fine no you'd be
like get a tourniquet quick
and that's what we need to be doing and
it's not just emotional there are
physical things that are going on
and when you guys notice those
difference you need to say quick get a
tourniquet I need help
yeah I've had a bunch of friends that
have gone through your protocol and like
you said so it's
the hyperbaric chamber what is it once a
day twice a day
um once a day is the preferred so 40
consecutive treatments the therapy does
build on the oxygen from the first
treatment the second treatment Builds on
that has a greater impact greater impact
so it does need to be 40 consecutive
sometimes we can't get
time you know if guys are still
Contracting and they're still going
overseas and stuff they can't do that
then it's like two days a two times four
hours apart or something like that
there's a certain protocol 34 hours in
between so they don't risk oxygen
toxicity but it's so safe there's not
any you know it's like you read the
prescription bottles for a lot of the
medications that our veterans are taking
and
you know two-thirds of them say may
cause suicidal tendency
I'm not a doctor I've never played one
on TV but that makes no sense to me why
even if it were a small chance if
they're already depressed and
discouraged why would we give them
something that that could be a side
effect and the impact we had one of our
veterans who was on 53 prescription
drugs at the same time
your kidney in your liver is not
designed to process that's how can that
be even free that should be malpractice
yeah that just makes no sense to me
either
but and half the time one prescription
they're giving you is to relieve the
symptom from the other prescription you
know it's like oh my goodness
so it's the hyperbaric chamber it's the
hormones it's the vitamin therapy
um it's a working out eating good yes
not you know stop freaking drinking yes
you know there are things that you need
to do to be responsible for this and I
get it we're such a world that we put
something in the microwave for a minute
we get frustrated because it's not done
cooking you know we want a One-Stop One
Step take this pill do this treatment
and I'm Healed I'm good to go
and they don't want to assume
responsibility you know the the things
that you're doing we've also done spec
scans on people that are drinking and
compared that to a TBI and the alcohol
is just as bad as the blast wave
exposure that's damaged your brain same
thing with the marijuana the illegal
drugs stop already do you really want to
get well like I said I get why you want
to match the symptoms but you're only
making it worse and so you need to do
those things you need to be working out
regularly there's a feel-good endorphin
I wrote something about a year and a
half ago that he was probably going to
be published I'm like okay I can't just
put in there it's a feel-good endorphin
so I researched it to see what that
endorphin skull was just called an
endorphin but it said it can have the
same impact as morphine
I'm like holy cow no wonder we feel so
good when we do an intense workout you
know
for your brain health the most effective
way to eat is the high protein low carb
you know and so make those choices do
those things that are not damaging
yourselves not destroying more than you
already have
and
you know so many you guys and gals have
been Fighters you know it's a different
battle now and you still have to know
the enemy you have to know the tactics
you have to put on your full armor every
day you know I can guarantee Jocko you
never went out in combat we're like yeah
I don't think I need my weapon today
I'll be good no that's crazy you didn't
say I'm not taking grenades with me
today or I'm not taking my water that's
you know extra weight I'll be good no
you put your full kit on
and you were prepared for plan A B C D
however far you needed to go you
probably put an extra grenade in there
just to be ready but you knew the enemy
you knew the tactics and you know
there's a component of spiritual battle
that's going on here too
and so you have to know that enemy you
need to put on your gear every day and
be prepared
and then the self-talk that we tell
ourselves
you know I think back to after I went
through that divorce and even though I
divorced him he's like you're fat you're
ugly nobody's ever going to love you
and so that tape that played over and
over in my brain was your unlovable
you're unlovable
with three children
and um like I said about when I was 28
you know surrendered everything to to
Christ I started I read a scripture and
says you're fearfully and wonderfully
made I'm like
wait wait wait
that's what Christ says about me okay
this other crap's a lie then and so
every time he would try to do that I'm
like nope that's not the truth and now
that tape rarely plays because he knows
that's not effective on me but we have
to reprogram that self-talk that we tell
ourselves you know and find something to
replace it you can't just say I'm going
to stop saying that because you got to
have something else to replace that with
and so you find out what that truth is
whatever you're struggling with I can
guarantee you there's a scripture in the
Bible that deals with that that once
you've got that memorized but um you've
you've got to do that Warfare it's a
different kind of battle but it is still
battle
and you're helping people with that
battle yes
um I know I read I read like a stat on
your organization 96.28 of the funds
that you receive go to treatment yeah
that's freaking awesome I am what my
board says politely very frugal but
um I did not take a salary for the first
10 years I was so
committed to making sure you guys got
the healing and not that because I take
a salary now I'm not committed but um
I wanted to prove ourselves as one of
those charities
that don't waste your money when you're
giving your money to US you can count on
it's not being wasted we're not having a
big party somewhere or you know making
our CEO come in on a flying something or
other or I don't know there's some
bizarre stuff out there and I think a
lot of these people when they started
probably had pure hearts but then the
money entices them I'm not a person
that's driven by money yeah we all need
money to survive in the world but that's
not why I wake up every day to you know
my mission is to wake up every day and
you know get help to our our veterans
and our gold star families and
yeah it's it's been an amazing run so
I'm very frugal how that money is spent
yeah and we're fortunate we've got a ton
of people that do volunteer you know if
you've got a skill or talent that you
can give you know if you're a CPA we
could use you know someone to donate an
audit you know we've got a lawyer on our
board so that's taken care of we don't
pay legal fees if you're a graphic
design artist or social media reach out
we need volunteers to help you know that
are willing to do those things for us as
well so we can continue to make our
dollar go so much further yeah that uh
again just going back to the program
which I've had friends go through I
haven't gone through it but I've had
friends go through it it's helped them
so much it's like think of the reset
that you get
by
I don't know if I should use this term a
freaking 40-day vacation where you get
to get this awesome treatment you get
good food you've got stress removed from
your life it's like a a reset on
people's minds then it's the the aspect
of the oxygen pressurized oxygen therapy
that you're getting to get that oxygen
into places in your brain that hasn't
had it for a while
it's a like a legitimate reset for
people and it's so helpful them and it
is expensive because you're sending
people you have to pay for their food
for their for their you know where
they're going to live they stay in a
hotel or whatever for this extended
period of time for 40 days
but that's what you need to do if you're
if you've if you've bounced off the
track you can't just get back on the
track in a day or two days you need to
you need to take a serious reset time
and get it back together and that's what
you're doing yeah it's a commitment and
we do have we work with facilities all
over the United States so sometimes
there's a clinic near you and you don't
have to go away for the 40 days but you
do have to then arrange your schedule so
if you're going in at seven o'clock in
the morning and it's a half an hour to
drive to get there it's going to be a
couple hours out of your day but it is
so worth that commitment for the life
change that happens
the battle you are you are
like the Pentagon of the battle
you're running things
um that's how you do it you know that's
what you do you do it for others just
like Mark
just like Mark
um what else are we up to date
we caught up is that what we're doing is
that where we're at right now maybe
maybe I'm trying to think if there's
anything else you know again just
reminder that if you need help we are
here
there's no excuse pick up the phone
we don't give you we don't tell people
who we're taking care of we your
information doesn't go anywhere we don't
report it to your commands
we're here to help obviously
we've already had a huge outpouring so
if you're someone that can help support
a veteran if you're a corporation you
can do you know a nice charity or
donation to our charity if you can
organize a fundraiser
you know we need the money to come in to
be able to continue to take care of
these guys I'll tell you what oh I'm not
going to be a happy camper
if we ever got to a place where someone
who has was struggling to reach out
calls finally and I have to say I'm
sorry we don't have any money to be able
to do that for you
yeah that ain't gonna happen I'm going
to be selling my own stuff
but I mean come on these are our men and
women
who've sacrificed greatly for us
and I feel like we do a terrible job as
a nation getting your health restored to
you
you know especially in our community
you get the best training you get the
best equipment you get the best missions
and then you come home and you get out
and I feel like it's that leaving a man
behind
you know like bye see you thanks you
know we're getting better we're
improving on some things but not all
where it should be the VA and then I
know there are some good va's but they
should be
disgraceful you know for the lack of the
care and the time that our veterans have
to wait
and again I'm not going to sit around
and wait and say well they should do
nope let's go
you know Mark's final words
as he got ready to go up the stairs that
day
or on me
what you guys know what he was saying
he's like I got the lead on this you
guys follow me I can't do it alone let's
go together as team
and that's what it is
you know and that's my challenge I'm
saying on me come on people let's go
whether you need help and you need to
reach out and ask for help whether you
can help support us whether you can
donate you know monthly whether you can
donate a service it's a team this
doesn't just happen because Debbie does
it every day
you know and I'm blessed choco by you
guys who Faithfully do the match when we
do the muster you know and on average
you'll raise 30 40 000 at A muster
and you know the different clients that
you've worked with they've spread the
word you know so thank you for the
impact that you guys have made and
continue to make you know
most of all thank you for being Mark's
Brothers
you know
that I'm blessed to be Mama Lee and you
know have you guys in as part of the
family and um
so so grateful
well uh like you said I mean Mark is
just still taking care of his teammates
still still giving
yeah you know he it's like you think
Mark has given everything
he's not he's still finding more to give
still saving guys still helping his
teammates and
and that's where that's what it's all
about
um
and again it's a choice no matter what
you're facing
whether
you know I had no choice the news that
was given to me in August 2nd I could
have stuffed my fingers in my ear I
could have refused to go home talk to
the caico officer
but I wanted to change the fact that
Mark was gone
and oftentimes in life we're faced with
Financial Health relationship issues or
maybe we don't have a choice maybe some
of them are self-inflicted like some of
mine were
but we do have a choice how we respond
and to curl up in a ball and feel sorry
for yourself or blame it on somebody
else and gonna change it
you got to get up you got to make a
choice and you gotta move forward
and I think a big part of some of the
struggles that I've seen are
are men and women is the shame issue
you know let go of that shame let go of
that guilt
if there is something you're involved in
ask for forgiveness
and then let it go don't keep picking it
up
and carrying it on
all right
probably a good place to stop
um Echo do you got any questions I have
nothing today good to see you yeah very
good to see you as always
um you need to speak a little bit less
though
don't they say sometimes
uh America's Mighty Warriors dot org
that's where you can be found
um Instagram America's Mighty
Twitter America's Mighty Facebook
America's Mighty Warriors you got a
YouTube channel
America's Mighty Warriors
so yeah I think one of those movies or
one of those movies out on the movies
one of the YouTubes is you Jocko when we
did the on me 20. oh yeah that's right
we did that was getting yep and we did
20 podcasts 20 days in a row won't do
that again but it's a lot different when
you're on up versus when you're
organizing it and planning it and
promoting it but um there's some great
wisdom we had so many great guys come on
there so yes we have a YouTube channel
anything else Mama Lee for us
let's go get some so we're definitely
gonna go get some
um
thanks so much for joining us today I
know um
I
didn't have you on here for a long time
and I was
super not ready to have you on here
and uh you know the way things happened
um George Monsour you know they uh they
had that book come out and you know we
were talking and I was like you know
come on the podcast and as soon as I got
done
we're recording with him I sent you a
text I said I just had George Monsour on
the podcast
I can do this and that means and I got
forced into that one you know I've got
forced into that one and I said you know
let's go and um
you know I think I think you've told me
many times that you've seen me cry you
Pro I think you've seen me cry more than
anybody so just you got the microphone
for you yeah that Mark's grave I'm like
oh that's probably not the image Jaco
wants out there but again people this is
who Jocko is you know we see your
picture you know the tough
you know knuckle dragger kind of you
know and that's not who you know and
you're always the
Square you know face when you're doing
the or whatever
I do have a square face but I tell you
what he does have a sense of humor
people he does have emotions and very
much carries that Mark's lost and
well
um yeah and that's like you know that's
again that's why I was it was really
hard for me to uh say you know what I
got to do this and it was George Monsour
and Mikey you know pushed me over the
edge
um because I know it's super emotional
obviously and and and if it's emotional
for me I can't even imagine how
emotional it is for you guys
um but
I'm so glad that you're able to come out
here today and and you know that you've
been with us through so much you know
you've been with us through
so many um
really really horrible things and you've
always been there for since since day
one
so thank you for all that
um thanks for bringing Mark into this
world my blessing
you raised a warrior
and you raised a warrior who
willingly sacrificed his life for his
friends
and we won't ever forget him
yeah and um thank you for all of that
thank you for what you're continuing to
do now
um
supporting all our veterans supporting
all our veteran families
your strength is absolutely incredible
it's absolutely incredible
um and
the work that you're doing
is
impacting the lives of countless people
people that I personally know
and all of that stems from
well from the mark that you made
yeah he made his Mark I was like and I
made my mark but yes and again everybody
else can make their mark
you're halfway through the deployment
get your butts up make a difference
that's what it is thank you Mama Lee
thank you love ya
and with that
Mama Lee has left the building
Lots going on in that podcast and you
know Mama Lee and I talked for a long
time before a long time after it so
just uh
very
heavy
and
very lucky that that
we had Mark in our lives and very lucky
and very blessed to have Mama Lee in our
lives so
um
you know as she said we need to live a
good life live a life to honor them
which means we need to go get after it
um
it's interesting because I know Mom I'm
trying to think when the first time I
met her was I'm probably at a Mazda but
I feel like I've known her for so long I
see her mostly at the Masters and events
or whatever and it's it's so interesting
how
you immediately understand why everyone
calls her mama Lee she's kind of like
your
you know the kind where she's just so
happy to see everyone you know and at
first I was like oh you know I must have
made an impression on her she's so nice
to me you know kind of a thing but it's
like oh yeah she's just like that she's
next to everybody Mama leaf
yeah so it it's this all makes sense the
way she like supports all this stuff all
the veterans so passionately you know
just all and actually kind of she made a
good point man with the Charities or
whatever where it's like oh yeah she
kind of mentioned it quick when she's
like oh I'm sure their heart's in the
right place at first but when the money
starts coming in then they'll like have
a party that's a little bit more lavish
or whatever
um
but
her like the the wit like what she
focuses on
is like so far from that almost like he
you can't really touch that element of
her yeah of her like Pursuit you know
for sure no she's and and I tried to
make it clear I don't know if I did or
not but like I have personal friends
that have gone through the treatment
program that her charity pays for and
it's had an immense positive effect
so one thing that's kind of cool is like
you remember those Charities when you
were a kid where they'd be like oh
if you donate this much money you're
going to get this many meals a day for
this kid can you like give you a name
and it would kind of connect it's sort
of like that now you don't get to know
the name of the veteran that you're
helping but when you donate like you are
helping a veteran get their life squared
away yeah and and I really do think that
this is like a great first step like if
you're gonna escalate
treatment
this to me is a great place to start
because it's you know it's natural and
there's no negative side effects
and you can get it done it's like 100
positive you know and I think if you try
this there's a decent chance like oh
you're gonna feel a lot better and then
maybe you can start to work some stuff
out look and there's more Extreme
Measures you know that people uh
treatments that people go to I mean
we've had Marcus Capone on like those
are some Extreme Measures yeah and
sometimes I think people get to that
point but I think this type of treatment
is a great place to start to see if we
can get some things under control
with kind of like the minimum amount of
in uh intervention you know what I'm
saying oh yeah fully and then it it
always
like like like real quick like before
you get surgery on your knee all right
you do rehab first before you get
surgery on your back you you know you
try stretching you try yoga you try some
injections you know you try other things
and then eventually they go okay look
man you're you've got a real issue that
can't be solved through this stuff so I
think this is sort of the
the first maybe it's the second step
because at first look man just quit
drinking eat healthy work out like see
how you feel then yeah you know okay
that doesn't work okay now we're gonna
try a hyperbaric chamber now we're gonna
try you know some of these vitamin
therapy some of these hormones so that's
I think the next escalation yeah and
then you know there's other things you
can do and then eventually you get to a
point where like okay like I got some
friends they they're at the end of the
Rope okay what do you need to do hey
you're gonna go and talk to the vets the
uh Marcus's thing and get some of that
what is it called psycho
what are those drugs called psychedelics
psychedelic therapy right you might get
there yeah but you know I would look at
it and some people are scared of that
right oh yeah
I'm scared of that like I don't want to
do that I don't think I need to do it
no it's not that I just it seems like a
risk
you know you start putting things in
your system maybe you open something up
you don't want to open up right so that
seems like a risk to me this is low risk
High reward yeah so again like I think I
know people I mean Marcus is a great
example of that right
um
you like so that you can get there and
then if you get there it's like okay I
get it but this stuff as an initial
start
why not give this a try see if you can
get some problems under control and
maybe turn out all right and yeah that's
what I think what's great about what
Mama Lee's doing I mean just just like I
said it's a 40 day I hate to call it a
vacation but it's kind of like a 40-day
vacation and you get perfect food you
get you know to work out you get this
awesome oxygen treatment so the
hyperbaric chamber treatment that's like
a reintroducing oxygen to places of your
brain that are damaged from lack of
oxygen yeah and like things get messed
up look I don't I I'm not a scientist
clearly you're not at all there's a
bunch of uh what is it called literature
about how these things help out right so
so consider that right where
if you have something physically damaged
on your brain and that's causing this
very specific behavior or whatever like
going to
some other treatment that doesn't
address the physical injury won't it
doesn't seem like I don't know like like
you I'm not a scientist but that part
still makes sense you know where like if
if you're in a spiraling thought pattern
that's different than if your brain is
physically damaged like you know like
you get for you know you hear we know
football players where like they had
literally said hey
I'm gonna commit suicide I'm not gonna
shoot myself in the head because I want
you to study my brother like there's
something Junior yeah yeah did you know
Junior Seau personally yeah from that no
not good he came into my club all the
time that I used to work at but um I I
met him like the same thing I met him
like at a bar one time it's super cool
super chill yeah and and and like that's
one of those cases you look at a guy
that killed himself you know Junior Seau
the guy is one of the most beloved
athletes in San Diego history and if
you're going to be a beloved athlete in
the city San Diego's a great City to be
a beloved athlete San Diego is just a
cool place you know there's a lot of fun
things to do and you go out in San Diego
it's not overwhelming like let's say
you're Michael Jordan in Chicago yeah
sure you're below but you're almost
getting mobbed right yeah there's a
level of chill in San Diego that if
you're Junior Seau yeah you're going out
in San Diego you're like having a good
time like I've been out like you like
you're saying dude you're saying I would
go to your Club go to your bar yeah I've
been in bars
like seal like bars that are where a
bunch of seals would go and like junior
said I wasn't there he's not getting mob
he's just you know having a beer or
whatever yeah I don't think there's a
lot of cities where that's the same yeah
you know so if you're going to be so
your Junior sale you're playing in the
NFL
you gotta basically unlimited money
right you live in a great City you're
famous in the city you're beloved in the
city because there's also athletes that
are in a city but they don't like them
because whatever they came from a
different team or whatever he's like
beloved in San Diego we're down for
junior sales yeah and and you take a guy
like that and he kills himself I mean
just horrible but more telling saying
straight up hey there's something wrong
yeah like this is how much I think
something you know so anyway the point
and the point there is
where that's not a spiraling thought
pattern that's just you know getting in
the way of is like
family life is Health causing them to
like hey maybe drinking will kind of
alleviate these thoughts and keeping
them up at night or whatever those are
like and that in and of itself is can
jam you up big time regardless of where
it comes from can Jeremy up big time but
it is different than if you have
straight up damage to your brain yeah so
the treatment is going to be different
and by the way we're gonna you know
we're seeing this now in a special
operations Community absolutely in the
seal community
that there's something going on
that is damaging guys brains and we
heard it from Sarah Wilkinson
her husband Chad was not the same guy
that she married and it's not like oh
he's been through some stuff and he's
you know he's got a different attitude
about such and such no he's a different
person
and we're we're seeing that and look
sometimes
being a different person maybe means
that you know I have a worse temper or
sometimes being a different person means
I'm more focused on something else right
there's a different level of like hey
he's a different person now
but occasionally and that's what we're
seeing in the SEAL Teams and it's
freaking awful you've got guys that
are getting into these mental places
that they absolutely no one expects them
to be in and you can't it this is the
equip actually the equivalent of Junior
Seau beloved seals everybody loves them
they have a great career they they're
respected by everybody they're in a
great position
and we're seeing that outcome
and so this well like you're talking
about when there's some kind of physical
issue with the brain
and I don't know what it is obviously
and actually unfortunately
no one really knows what it is yeah they
haven't been able to say oh yes this is
what happened to Junior seau's brain
here's the impact here's the nerves that
got rattled here's the reconnections
that got made here's the shortfalls that
happened no one said that yet no one
said that about
seals that have taken their own lives oh
okay here's the thing here's what they
went through here's what we needed to
stop and no one's saying that
but one thing that's happening right now
is people are saying hey we can't do
this anymore we need to identify we we
identify the symptom that is guys are
killing themselves we got to figure out
what's causing it and then figure out
how to how to how to get that under
control I mean it's absolutely horrific
to see this happening
so I think what Mama Lee is doing this
this
this intervention with and like I said
I've seen the impact that it's had on
guys and she's just continuing to get
out there and make this happen and you
know as we talked about this is Mark
Mark Lee like I said there's a guy that
Lit you think he's given everything but
he's still trying to take care of his
teammates so bro I love looking at stuff
like that like how she would say you
know and obviously mommy's very
spiritual person
um but the idea of like you know like
you have this war right you have the bad
guys against the good guys and you know
the bad guy takes out a good guy oh but
did he take out that good guy not really
because the very taking out that good
guy kind of spread all this other good
you know this other goodness so it kind
of kind of went beyond the grave kind of
stuff and literally that's true it
literally actually factually true and I
thought about that too when when Ryan
Manion was on also because she said it
she was like hey she she's like in a way
it was a blessing because I would have
never done this and this and this if
this terrible thing didn't happen and I
was like huh that's crazy that's kind of
true or it is true straight up sure but
you know at the same time it doesn't
change the fact that it's like a tragic
loss or whatever but it's like it's
spawned like that sacrifice like spawned
so many other good things that literally
wouldn't happen wouldn't have got
spawned yeah
crazy Mark continues to give
yep and it's
I wish I could do his personality
Justice yeah
um because it's just one of a kind you
know
so that's what we're doing we're trying
to live we're trying to live good lives
in order to do that you need some
well you need some good fuel to be
honest with you
yep yeah easy supplements good
supplements supplements with Integrity
yep yep chocolate fuel got some protein
called milk ready to drink too by the
way yeah
look the chocolate one look the
chocolate one is just straight delicious
uh the vanilla is also delicious
you know got to give it up for for
Keegan Keegan Roberts came up with the
perfect description the vanilla's like
melted ice cream
and bananas the bananas
yeah so you know what you know why we
because normally you don't go normally
you don't go chocolate vanilla banana
right that's not normal what's normal
strawberry maybe strawberry right sure
yeah you want you know why you go banana
because the banana was so freaking good
oh yeah just let me start making this
banana one uh ready to drink milk get
that stuff yep make it happen yep don't
forget about your joints big deal
because once they go it don't matter how
much protein you get joints don't move
well it always matters so much support
your muscles with protein support your
joints with joint Warfare yep it's true
super krill oil in there vitamin D3 in
there Cold War immunity important as
well
especially nowadays actually not even
the missionaries all the time Community
yeah
we're making the best possible products
we can
uh if you go to Wawa get yourself some
drinks if you go to Vitamin Shoppe you
can get everything at Vitamin Shop you
can get it stuff should be at the
military commissary I had somebody reach
out the other day say it wasn't their
military commissary go tell the manager
be a Karen
be like hey there's no Jocko fuel here
no I'm just kidding don't be a Karen
butt maybe in a respectful way say hey
can we get some Jocko fuel up in this
piece yeah uh Hannaford
Dash stores and look I got the same
message about Hannaford
HEB Murphy's Myers Meyer any of these
stores if they don't have Jocko fuel in
stock let them know be like hey we're
looking for that jogger fuel where's it
at that way they can you know help us
get the logistics squared away get more
stuff sent to them so there you go or
you go to jockofuel.com and you can get
all the stuff as well order it make it
happen if you need some Jiu Jitsu gear
to wear on your body which you might
need rash guards we're not doing the
freaking uh pancreation just going naked
no we're not doing that we're not doing
that though some of these like Dean
Lister sometimes he wants to wear them
little Sun gals right yeah he goes in
that direction he leans in that
direction he doesn't do it anymore
freaking horrible when he used to do
that if you don't know what a sun GAO is
it's like a look they're basically like
a bikini for a man
and as a Brazilian thing which look cool
man nothing against the Brazilian
culture that's their culture yeah on the
beach yeah on the beach but when you
come into the on the mats of Justice
we're gonna leave Dallas we don't want
it to be the mats of just ass that's
right we want it to be the mass of
justice so so put some clothes on right
put some ghee on put a ghee on put a
rash guard on
and we got all that stuff and guess what
it's all made in America you know it's
interesting I'm talking to some people
yesterday
they don't even know that it's made in
America they're like oh it's really it's
all made him yes it's 100 made in
America
that's what one of that's what makes it
awesome look if we were making it
overseas and it was as good high
qualities that'd be cool yeah cool
but the next level is made in America
so originusa.com by the way we're
starting to backfill all that hunt gear
so if you needed hunt gear get on there
order yourself some hunt gear I know
listen might seem like oh hunt says not
for another few months as you know hunt
sneezing sneaks up on you and you're
like dude I haven't been shooting enough
it's gonna sneak up on you get your hunk
gear originusa.com made in America yep
it's true also chocolate star called
Jaco store so you can get your
discipline equals Freedom shirts and
hats and it isn't stuff good represent
represent on the path hey we're on the
back you guys got this where we have the
reset yeah chuckle reset that's a path
it's a path a program for it's kind of
is that a competition would you call it
a conversation I'd say you know what I
would say it is what it's a reset yeah
that's what it's called that's what it
is this one equals Freedom reset get
yourself back on the path and it's
amazing I said this a long time I think
I said it to Jordan Peterson a long time
ago sure JP
you fix one thing like you said you if
you write down what you're supposed to
do tomorrow tonight and you do it that's
awesome and you had a good day and you
made progress in your life now imagine
if you did that for a week now imagine
if you did that for a month now you
imagine if you did that for a year now
imagine if you did that for five years
where would you be if you actually did
what you were supposed to do that's what
the reset's about okay so it's a in um
the deafreset.com oh that's yeah that's
where it's all outline boom yeah so if
you want to represent yes yesore.com
also we have a thing called the shirt
Locker it's a subscription scenario get
a new shirt every month different
designs
seem to like that one but yeah check
that one out I like that most recent one
the no free dough for me no free
dopamine free dopamine that's part of
the reset man hey if you're wearing a no
free dopamine shirt and you're holding
your phone in your hand and you're
scrolling you you are you can't oh yeah
you can't do it you'll be like hey
you're gonna put that away you know it's
free dopamine yeah exactly right you
know it's free dopamine yeah so get away
from that
um there you go that's the that's the
sherlocker don't forget to subscribe to
the podcast don't forget we got jock on
the ground we've been releasing a bunch
of those putting out words little
a little additional information
if you have questions by the way you
need to add more questions to the doc or
almost out so you when you guys send
email those questions
then we upload the doc and we answer
them so there you go
um check that out dracounderground.com
don't forget we got a YouTube channel
don't forget about origin USA YouTube
channel don't forget about psychological
warfare don't forget about Flipside
canvas Dakota Meyer making cool stuff to
hang on your wall
don't forget about books and by the way
if you want to get books you can get any
book that Debbie Lee Mama Lee has either
helped write or she's been a part of in
any way she sells them on her website a
lot of times they're signed so if you
want to get books you can get it through
her website America's Mighty Warriors
dot org and you go to store and you can
buy some of the books there look a bunch
of books you guys know my books oh I
only cry for the living Holly McKay
unbelievable book that's from Jocko
publishing final spin
there's news on Final spin news yeah
we're keeping it on the DL but yeah
there's the cool things very cool things
we'll say very cool things are happening
with final spin
so that's that's pretty awesome
um I look forward to talking more about
that and as we go through that process
by the way way of the warrior kid five
is out
weigh the warrior kid five is out you
may not have known that I didn't do a
great job of whatever promoting it yeah
I'm not talking trash but yeah I do a
bad job it was not promoted in the way
that the other ones were because the
other ones I was like I felt the hype I
felt the bill I couldn't wait and now
you tell me this I'm like dang okay this
was I'm reading it it's just like you
know when you when you write something
and then it takes a while for it to come
out right and then you read it again
you're like yeah yeah you kind of feel
and I've always said this about way of
the warrior kid
when I read them I kind of don't feel
like I wrote it because it's written in
another it's written from the aspect of
you know a little kid yeah and so I'm
reading I'm like oh that's a cool I'm
like oh yeah
is out right now order it and then order
one two three four whoever you know
whatever kids you know uh Mikey and the
dragons get that for little kids about
faced by hackworth extreme ownership
than economy leadership we got Echelon
front
echelonfront.com which our leadership
consultancy that's what we do every
single day this is a pretty cool
statement every single day there's
somebody from Echelon front in the world
teaching leadership to a company
probably two or three of them sometimes
five or six of them so that's what we do
we solve problems through leadership go
to echelonfront.com we do Live Events
too we got by the way the battlefield
sold out
um the next one we're gonna do is Little
Bighorn but Gettysburg is sold out for
now but get on there early these things
sell out the the muster
Orlando this is the next one April 3 3rd
through the fifth
check that one out and then it's going
to be Dallas after that in October 18th
through the 20th look these things all
sell out so if you want to come please
get on there ashlandfront.com go
register we also have the online
Training Academy extreme ownership
Academy we're on there all the time we
are putting out word we are answering
questions you want to ask me questions
go on join the academy
and then ask me your question say hey
Jocko I had a question boom now I'll
answer your question you've got a
leadership issue you got a life issue
you got a jiu jitsu issue we can get an
answer extreme ownership.com we got a
bunch of course we put on free courses
right now
we gotta we got a course Dave Burke and
I did a curfew yes good deal Dave we did
a course about extreme ownership and
then Jamie Cochran and I did a course
about the barriers to extreme ownership
so check that one out
um if you want to help
service members active and retired guess
what you can do
Mama Lee's got an incredible
organization you heard all about what it
did today what it does say hey by the
way she as she was leaving she also
mentioned she's hiring she's looking to
hire someone so if you want to help out
with the administrative side or you want
to volunteer with some of the other
areas let her know
um America's Mighty Warriors dot org
reach out this is a great organization
and also on Instagram she is uh at
America's Mighty Twitter America's
Mighty Facebook America's Mighty
Warriors YouTube America America's
Mighty Warriors that's how you connect
with Mama Lee that's how you can help
out that's how you can get involved and
if you want to get you know involved
with Echo Charles
or with me I am at jockle link Echo is
adequal Charles don't forget that Echo
Charles's Twitter
he compromised it
it's true right I was like worried when
you're when your Twitter got I'll use
the term loosely hacked I was like dang
like this is weird like how what kind of
what kind of people are out there what
kind of Nefarious people out there I
pictured you know when you see uh uh uh
Mission Impossible type movie yes and
the guys show up and they plug in little
wires and they're running through a
program to figure out what the password
is yeah and there's nine people on the
radio that are calling back to a big
Mainframe computer to break in and get
the password yeah sure when you first
told me that that's what I pictured okay
and then you tell me what happened yeah
and I realized you were just dumb
I realized you were just dumped and you
don't did some dumb [__] yes sir that's
true hey live and learn so Echo
gave away his password lost his thing he
got fished but it's back but his back
totally back way back so yeah if you
want to reconnect him I mean Echo
Charles he now has 19 followers on
Twitter yep
how many did you used to have I
appreciate every single one of them did
you know what you used to have
um yeah 50 000. do you have 50 000 I
think it was like seven seventy thousand
look at that sure they're all wondering
where 71 I don't know yeah we should
have made up a better story you know hey
that's real do you know you should have
said I left Twitter because of whatever
oh my political views political or
something like this yeah yeah there you
go
um so there you go that's where you can
get in touch with us
and uh
thanks once again to Mama Lee
for
everything
we could never have asked for a better
teammate in your son we could have never
asked for a better supporter and we
could have never asked for a better
second mom for so many of us so thank
you Mama Lee
and thanks to all the military personnel
out there
and especially a thanks to the military
families
all of you you sacrifice so much for our
country when you support your military
service member
so thank you and then a solemn thanks
for the gold star families we are
forever indebted to what you have given
to us
and also thanks to our police and law
enforcement our firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol Secret Service all the
First Responders out there and and your
families as well you all keep keep us
safe but you're able to do your job
thanks to the support and sacrifice of
your families so thanks to our First
Responders and thanks to your families
as well
and to everybody else out there
let's think about Mark Lee
let's think about his last letter home
and think about that for him to be in
combat to be in danger on a daily basis
and what he says in that letter is he
asks us to pass on the kindness the love
the precious gift of human life
what he wanted us to do was help each
other what he wanted us to do was commit
more random acts of kindness
what he wanted us to do
was take less
and give more
and that's coming from a man
who gave everything he had
so let's give more let's do better let's
be better
for Mark
and until next time zeko and Jocko
out